[موسيقى]
حصاد معكم جلال شهداء في الوقت الذي
احدثكم في احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه
من يمي وتصريح للجزيره قال فيه وزير
داخليه حكومه المجلس العسكري ان فرنسا لا
تنوي تنفيذ قرارها بالانسحاب من النيجر
الى الخرطوم على واقعي معارك بين الجيش
السوداني ودعم السريع تسببت في انقطاع
كامل للكهرباء من ثلاث ولايات تشكل اقليم
كردفان
وفي وارسو حيث تريدنا هذه الصور يعقد
مؤتمر وارسو للامن بمشاركه وزراء دفاع
اوروبيين وقاده عسكريين بالاضافه الى
خبراء في مجالات الامن والطاقه
في موضع الحصاد
لليوم الرابع وتحت حمايه امنيه مشدده مئات
المستوطنين يقتحمون الاقصى وشرطه الاحتلال
تمنع المصلين من الوصول لباحاته الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه تقول ان الاحتلال يحاول خلق
وقائع جديده بالقدس الشرقيه والفصائل
تتوعد
على وقع توتر متصاعد بين برشتينا وبلغراد
وزير داخليه كوسوفو يقول للجزيره ان
مجموعات في صربيا تتدرب لتنفيذ هجمات
جديده ويتهم بالسعي لاحتلال بلدات في
الشمال والرئيس الصربي يحمل مجموعه من صرب
كوسوفو مسؤوليه قتل الشرطي قبل اسبوع
لتاكيد استمرار دعم اوكرانيا وايضا يجري
اتصالات مع قاده الحلفاء لتهدئه المخاوف
بعد استثناء مساعدات كياف من اتفاق
الكونجرس لتجنب الاغلاق والبيت الابيض
يقول ان عدم توفير التمويل لاوكرانيا حتى
لفتره قصيره يمكن ان يحدث فرقا كبيرا في
ساحه المعركه
باريس في مرمى اتهامات يمي المجلس العسكري
يقول ان لدى فرنسا خطه لاغتيال قاده
ووزراء في النيجر ويتهم باريس بالتواصل مع
من سماهم ارهابيين في النيجر ويؤكد وجود
تسجيلات تثبت ذلك
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصات
الرقميه ناقشنا الاتهامات الحاده من
المجلس العسكري في النيجر لفرنسا باعداد
خطه اغتيال قاده ووزراء في البلاد بهدف
سعزعه الاستقرار استطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع التالي في رايكم في اي سياق تاتي
اتهامات المجلس العسكري في النيجر لفرنسا
ردودكم جاءت على الشكل التالي 35 في المئه
وضعوا الاتهامات في سياق التوتر بين باريس
وانيامي منذ انقلاب العسكري
29% اعتبروا ان هدف الاتهامات رغبه يمي في
الاسراع باكمال سحب القوات الفرنسيه بينما
قالت قرابه سته قرابه 36% ان الاتهامات
ترتبط باضطراب امني ومقتل جنود على حدود
النيجر هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المستطاع الرقميه تجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوريا
[موسيقى]
تتابعنا في الحصاد ايضا
ارمينيا تصدق على الانضمام الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وروسيا تعتبر الخطوه
قرارا خاطئه
[موسيقى]
اقتحم نحو 800 مستوطن ومتطرف باحات المسجد
الاقصى في رابع ايام عيد العرش اليهودي
والصاحبسه امنيه مشدده وقال مسؤول في
الاوقاف الاسلاميه ان قوات كبيره من شرطه
الاحتلال تنتشر في باحات المسجد الاقصى
وعند ابوابه وتفرض قيودا مشدده على دخول
الفلسطينيين لا سيما الشبان وتحتجز بطاقات
هويه من تسمح له بالدخول وقد عززت شرطه
الاحتلال قواتها ودفعت بمئات من عناصرها
الى البلده القديمه ومحيطها لتامين
احتفالات اليهود في عيد العرش الذي يستمر
اسبوعا
مسجد خالص للمسلمين هذا واقع يسعى المحتل
لتغييره
في فتره الاعياد اليهوديه بشكل خاص تزداد
وتيره اقتحامات الاقصى
تضاعف خلال الايام الماضيه عدد مقتحميه من
المستوطنين والمتطرفين اليهود
بتسهيلات وحمايه من شرطه الاحتلال يجولون
في باحاته وفي ازقه البلده القديمه من
القدس المحتله
وبشكل يمس بحرمه الاقصى ويستفز مشاعر
المسلمين يتبعون صلواتهم وطقوسهم
التلموديه عند عتبات الاقصى بالرقص
والغناء
كذلك يفعلون منذ بدء عيد العرش اليهودي
الذي يستمر حتى يوم الجمعه المقبل
في المقابل يضيق على الفلسطينيين
قوات من شرطه الاحتلال المنتشره بكثافه في
باحات المسجد الاقصى وعند ابوابه تفرض
قيود المشدده على دخول المصلين اليه
وتحديدا الشبان منهم
ولن يكتمل المشهد دون الاعتداء على
المرابطات في محيط الاقصى واعتقال بعضهم
صحيح ان الجماعات الاستيطانيه وجماعات
الهيكل المزعوم المتطرفه تستغل الاعياد
الدينيه عند اليهود للمس بحرمه الاقصى غير
ان ما يحدث هو نهج رسمي لتل ابيب الساعيه
لفرض التقسيم الزماني والمكاني لقبله
المسلمين الاولى
اما تقسيم الزمني فيعني تخصيص اوقات محدده
لدخول المسلمين واخرى خاصه باليهود من
خلال اقتسام الساعات والايام طوال العام
اذا تم ذلك فانه سيتوجب على المسلمين
افراغ المسجد الاقصى لساعات محدده يوميا
كي يصلي فيه اليهود ثلاث صلوات في اليوم
وتسعى سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه الى
تخصيص الاقصى لليهود خلال اعيادهم التي
تصل الى 100 يوم مضافا اليها ايام السبت
اما تقسيم المكاني فالمقصود به اسرائيليا
تخصيص امكنه وزوايا من المسجد الاقصى لكل
من الطرفين وهنا تسعى حكومه الاحتلال
لاقطاع منطقتين من المسجد
هي اذا محاوله للاخلال بالوضع التاريخي
القائم ذاك الذي يقصر الصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى على المسلمين مع اتاحه فرصه زيارته
للسياح من غير المسلمين في منحا مغاير
تماما تمضي سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مستمحت اول مره للمستوطنين بتنفيذ
اقتحامات المسجد الاقصى عام 2003
اقتحامات يريدها وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي ان تتم على مدار الساعه مع
امكانيه اداء المقتحمين الصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى صحيفه
كشفت عن مطالبه اتمار بنك فير بذلك في
رساله وجهها لاعضاء يمينيين في الكنيست
بن فير قال وفقا للصحيفه انه يامر بشده في
ان يدعم وزراء الصهيونيه الدينيه مقترحه
دكتور هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات
لابحاث السياسات دكتور ما الواقع الذي
يسعى الاحتلال فرضه في المسجد الاقصى
والقدس
اولا اسمح لي ان اذكر بما كان الامر عليه
قبل 2003 حتى نعرف حجم التغيير الذي حدث
بالعقدين الاخيرين قبل يعني ما يجري حاليا
كان زوار المسجد الاقصى من غير المسلمين
يحصلون على موافقه للزياره من الاوقاف
الاسلاميه
وعلى ان لا يقوموا باي طقوس دينيه وكانت
اعدادهم من اليهود اعداد قليله جدا
بالعشرات وفي اقصى الحالات بالمئات الان
يقتحم المسجد الاقصى في كل عام اكثر من 50
الف يعني مستعمر يهودي وفي الاعياد في كل
يوم مئات المستعمرين المستوطنين يقومون
بالاقتحام ويمارسون يعني الطقوس الدينيه
والاغاني
والندوات والرقصات وكل هذه المسائل في
التمهيد لخطوات القادمه
لانه مع احترامي لما جاء في التقرير
التقسيم الزماني والمكان قد حصل يعني سواء
في اعياد او بدون اعياد كل يوم من السابعه
والنصف الى الحاديه عشره والنصف دكتور ما
الواقع الذي يحاول الاحتلال فرضه اذا
هم يريدون ان يكون هناك اماكن مخصصه
لليهود وان يكون هناك صلاه بشكل دائم
وهناك دعوات باقامه كونس يهوديه في المسجد
الاقصى رويدا رويدا حتى يتم تطبيق ما حدث
في الحرم الابراهيمي حيث هناك ساعات محدده
بداخل الحرم لليهود بشكل كامل وساعات
للمسلمين وبالتالي الخطوه على المدى
الابعد هي هدم يعني الاقصى وهذا ما تقوله
جماعات كثيره هناك 52 مؤسسه يعني
تنادي بهذه من الاقصى وبناء هيكل سليمان
المزعوم بدلا عنه وبالتالي
كشف في الايام الاخيره عن نفق جديد تم
يعني
بنائهم منذ ثلاثه اشهر يمتد من ساحه
البراق حتى القصور الروماني وهذا يدل على
ان هذه الحفريات الممتده هي بحد ذاتها
تشكل تهديدا مباشرا على المسجد الاقصى
دكتور
الذي وصفته كيف ترى الاستجابه الاسلاميه
والعربيه للمطالب بوقف ما يحصل في الاقصى
والقدس
المرابطون في الاقصى من اهل القدس ومن
شعبنا في 48 يقومون بجهود كبيره ولكن هذا
لا يكفي لان حجم الهجمه وهجم المخططات
وحجم الموازنات المخصصه لتنفيذ هذا المخطط
اكبر من طاقاتهم وامكانياتهم خاصه ان
الفلسطينيين من بقيه المناطق في الضفه
الغربيه وفي قطاع غزه لا يستطيعون القدوم
الى القدس ليقوموا بالدفاع عن المسجد
الاقصى اما بالنسبه لرده الفعل الرسميه
الفلسطينيه والدول العربيه والجامعه
العربيه فهي اقل بكثير من حجم الخطر هم
يعتقدوا ان مجرد المناشده او المطالبه
للمؤسسات الدوليه او الاداره الامريكيه او
مجرد التهديد بان هناك
انفجار سيحدث وبان هذا لا يمكن ان يمر هذا
سيمنع هذه المخططات هذه التهديدات اللفظيه
لا تكفي يجب ان يوضع مخطط كامل وامكانيات
كامله
ويشعر كل الناس وكل الاطراف في المنطقه
وفي العالم ان المضي في هذا المخطط سيؤدي
الى انفجار كبير ليس بالكلام وانما بالفعل
وهذا لا ياتي بشكل عاطفي وبرود فعل وانما
يجب ان يكون نتيجه وعي وتخطيط وتنظيم
واستعداد للتصدي بكل ما يتطلبه هذا التصدي
من امكانيات دكتور هاني المصري مدير مركز
مسارات لابحاث السياسات في رام الله شكرا
لك قبل ان نتابع في ملفات الحصاد نتابع
هذه الصور المباشره التي تاتينا الان من
مجلس النواب الامريكي الذي بدا التصويت
على عزل رئيس مجلس النواب الجمهوري كذا
مكارثي طبعا سنعود لنواكب هذا التطور في
مجلس النواب الامريكي مع مراسلنا في
واشنطن لاحقا خلال الحصاد
[موسيقى]
اتهم وزير الداخليه الكوسوفي جلال
صربيا بالتورط المباشر في الهجوم الذي
شنته مجموعه صربيه في شمال كوسوفو واودى
بحياه شخص وقال في تصريحات للجزيره ان
كوسوفو حصلت على ادله من ضمنها صور ووثائق
تؤكد هذا التورط
صربيا متورطه بشكل مباشر في هذه المحاوله
التي ترمي الى غزو جزء من اراضينا
المسؤولون الكبار متورطون بشكل مباشر بدءا
من الرئيس ووزير الدفاع وقائد الجيش
والامن كلهم متورطون ولدينا الادله على
ذلك هذه المجموعه التي تضم على الاقل 80
ارهابيا تدربت في معسكرات صربيه لدينا
ادله لان الطائرات المسيره التي حجزناها
تضمنت صورا لهذه التدريبات ثم ان هناك
حجما كبيرا من الاسلحه والسيارات المصفحه
وكثير من التجهيزات التي لا يمكن ان توجد
في السوق ولا في السوق السوداء ولدينا
وثائق تثبت هذا التورط
وقال وزير الداخليه الكوسوفي جلال ان
صربيا تريد احتلال شمال كوسوفو في سيناريو
يشبه ما حصل في اقليم دومباس الذي الحقته
روسيا بها على حد وصفه تصريح الوزير
الكوسوفي للجزيره جاء على خلفيه الهجوم
الذي شنته مجموعه صربيه في شمال كوسوفو
واودى بحياه شخص
الزعماء والصرب مهووسون بالحصول على
الاراضي نيتهم كانت احتلال البلديات
الشماليه والحاقها ليقوموا في المستقبل
بما سيسمونه مسارا سياسيا يعلنون بعده
انها اصبحت جزءا من صربيا انه نفس
السيناريو في دومباس عندما احتلتها روسيا
يتكرر مع اختلاف الفاعلين
وزير داخليه كوسوفو قال ايضا ان الادانه
الدوليه للصربيا غير كافيه داعيا الى فرض
عقوبات عليها واشدد الوزير في تصريحاته
الجزيره على انه في حاله غياب هذه
العقوبات فان صربيا ستكرر ما فعلته وفقا
لقوله
ما نتوقعه ليس مجرد تصريحات ولكن عقوبات
ضد صربيا من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده وكل العالم الديمقراطي
الادانه ليست كافيه ان هذا يشجع صربيا على
ان تخطط بطريقه اكبر لتتدخل في جمهوريه
كوسوفو اذا لم يضغط المجتمع الدولي على
قياده صربيا ولم يعاقب سلوكها الاجرامي
فصربيا ستكرر ما فعلته
وفي بلغراد قال الرئيس الصربي الكسندر
فوتشيتش ان مجموعه من صربي كوسوفو هم
المسؤولون عن قتل الشرطي في كوسوفو جهته
اكد رئيس اركان الجيش الصربي ميلان
موسيلفوفيتش ان عدد قواته على طول الحدود
مع كوسوفو عاد الى وضع الطبيعي موضحا انه
تم خفض عدد الجنود من ثمانيه الاف 3850
الى اربعه الاف وخمسمائه وكان وزير الدفاع
الصربي
ميلوفتش قال انه اذا تلقى الجيش الصربي
امرا من الرئيس بالهجوم على كوسوفو فانه
سينفذ هذه المهمه بكفاءه ومهنيه ونجاح وفق
التعبيره ورفض اتهام بلاده بالتخطيط لضم
اراضي كوسوفو الشماليه
تنضم الينا من لندن دونيكا ايمينيه
الباحثه المتخصصه في شؤون البلقان سيده
دونيكا ماذا تقرئين في اتهامات وزير
الداخليه الكوسوفي لصربيا
بمحاولتها لضم مناطق واقاليم في شمال
كوسوفو
في الحقيقه هذه المخاوف هي حقيقيه لاننا
نتحدث عن حقيقه في كلا الطرفين طبعا شهدت
الاراضي الكوسوفيه هجوما ارهابيا ولكننا
في هذه المرحله لا نعرف
لو تم التخطيط لهذه الهجمات من قبل
مجموعات صربيه منظمه او
اولئك الذين هم في الاجزاء الشماليه من
كوسوفو يتعاونون مع صربيا سواء كان ذلك
بدعم مباشر او غير مباشر من صربيا من
الواضح ان الشخص هو مقرب من رئيس ونعرف
ايضا ان القوات الصربيه تتحرك على الحدود
مع كوسوفو والهدف هو رفع الاجراءات
الامنيه على الحدود مع كوسوفو وفي
السيناريو الاسود سوف يؤدي ذلك
شراره
وبعد ذلك تتدخل القوات الصربيه ويتعين على
الشرطه الكسريه ان تنسحب وفي الوقت الراهن
المنطقه في تلك الاجزاء يمكن ان تصبح
محميه على المستوى الدوري وبعد ذلك تتدخل
صربيا من خلال حوار سياسي لضم هذه الاجزاء
او لاعلان الاستقلال الذاتي للصرب في
الاجزاء الشماليه من كوسوفو هناك دعوات
وجهت الى الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هو اللفت بان الرئيس
الصربي حمل المسؤوليه لمن وصفها
بمجموعات مسلحه في شمال كوسوفو ما مدى
ارتباط هذه المجموعات بحسب معلوماتك ما
مدى ارتباطها
بدوائر الدوائر الرسميه في في صربيا
هناك روابط رسميه مع صربيا لان
الشخصيه المسؤوله عن هذه العمليات مقربه
من وفي الوقت نفسه هو الزعيم
لحزب صربيا سياسي يتمثل في البرلمان في
كوسوفو وايضا في الحكومه
الكسوفيه اذا لديه روابط مباشره هو اليد
المباشره لرئيس بوتشوتش في كوسوفو ويعمل
لصالح اجنده النظام في صربيا والحكومه في
صربيا اذا كل قرار قام به الصرب في كوسوفو
او لكل قرارا يقومون به تجري اجتماعات
مسبقه مع الرئيس فوتشيتش وفي خلال هذه
الاجتماعات يتم التنسيق على اعلى
المستويات بين هذه
المجموعات
والحزب في كوسوفو وهذا التنسيق يتم رسميا
مع صربيا وبالاضافه الى ذلك هناك روابط
غير رسميه الا وهي التمويل الذي تتلقى هذه
المجموعات الصربيه في الاجزاء الشماليه من
كوسوفو من قبل صربيا وهي تحت ذريعه
الحمايه
للعرقيه الصربيه في
اجزاء الشماليه من كوكب تحديات للشرطه في
كوسوفو منذ اعلان الاستقلال شكرا السيده
دونيكا الباحثه المتخصصه في شؤون البلقاء
[موسيقى]
الى ملف اخر حيث قالت جون كيربي منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي ان رئيس الامريكيه جو
بايدن اجرت اتصالا مع حلفاء بلاده لتنسيق
الدعم لاوكرانيا اضاف في مؤتمر صحفي ان
زعماء الدول الحليفه لوشنطن لم يعربوا عن
اي مخاوف لاداره بايدن بشان عدم استمرار
الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا
لا يمكننا تحت اي ظرف السماح بانقطاع
الدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا الوقت ليس في
مصلحتنا لدينا ما يكفي من التمويل لتلبيه
احتياجات اوكرانيا في ساحه القتال ولكننا
بحاجه الى ان يتحرك الكونجرس لضمان عدم
حدوث اي انقطاع لهذا الدعم وهذا يكتسي
اهميه خاصه مع السعي وزاره الدفاع لتجديد
مخزونات الدعم لاوكرانيا انقطاع الدعم ولو
لفتره قصيره من الزمن يمكن ان يحدث فرقا
كبيرا في ساحه المعركه
اذا بغينا من جلور لاري كورب مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه السابق وكبير الباحثين
في مركز التقدم الامريكي سيد كورب ماذا
تقرا في مروحه الاتصالات الواسعه التي
اجراها الرئيس جو بايدن بمن سماهم حلفاء
اوكرانيا
يعني ليطمئنهم ربما من ان الدعم لاوكرانيا
لن يتوقف رغم ما حصل في الكونغرس
في الحقيقه دائما ما نجد اشخاصا في نظامنا
السياسي قد لا يوافقون على سياسه الاداره
الامريكيه اعتقد انه ما حصل هو محاوله عدم
الافراط او المبالغه في الرد العلمي
بالنسبه الى موضوع التمويل وفشل مشروع
القانون قال الناس ان الدعم لاوكرانيا سوف
يتوقف ولكن الحقيقه هي ان الامور متعدده
على مستوى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهناك معالجه لهذا الموضوع
والمساعدات سوف تستمر لاشهر ولكن هناك
مخاوف مرتبطه ببلدان اخرى مثل بولندا
وسلوفاكيا اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تحاول ان تتعاون مع الدول
الاوروبيه في هذا المجال ولكن في التحليل
العام نعرف انه في الولايات المتحده الام
ريكيه هناك محاولات للضغط حتى النهايه
وبعد ذلك تسير الامور تراهن موسكو بحسب
تصريحاتها على ما تسميه تعب حلفاء
اوكرانيا من دعمها المستمر لوقت طويل هل
هناك مؤشرات لهذا بتقييمك
اعتقد انه كما ذكرت نرى في سلوفاكيا على
سبيل المثال هذا التعب تودس لباقي ان تقدم
المساعدات
العسكريه الاقتصاديه وليس العسكريه هناك
مخاوف مرتبطه بهذا الامر اذا ما قرر الروس
ان يقوموا بعمليات عسكريه في بولندا ايضا
قالوا انهم يعودون العمل على تعزيز
الدفاعات وايضا لدينا في المجر الحكومه
لديها بعض المواقف المغايره ولكن بشكل عام
عدد كبير من البلدان يستمر في التزامه
تجاه اوكرانيا وهذا الالتزام الذي بدا منذ
عام ونصف وهذا طبعا فاجا عدد كبير من
الاطراف وخصوصا الرئيس بوتين ما الاعباء
التي تقع على على كاهل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في حال
كره الثلج هذه من التعب كما وصفتها موسكو
موسكو تعب
حلفاء اكياس من دعمها ما الاعباء التي
ستقع على اداره الرئيس بايدن بتقديرك في
هذه الحاله
اعتقد ان ما سوف تقوم به الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو الاستمرار بما بدات نحن نقدم
المساعدات الاقتصاديه والعسكريه اكثر من
100 مليار دولار امريكي حتى اللحظه
الراهنه واعتقد ان الاكثريه الساحقه من
الكونجرس الامريكي والشعب الامريكي تدعم
ذلك يجب ان نتنبا عندما نستمع الى هذه
التصريحات عندما كنت اعمل في وظيفه
الحكوميه قال احدهم لي ان التصريحات
السياسيه الداخليه تكون موجهه الى
الناخبين ورفع الصوت ونبره الى ما هنالك
ولكن في نهايه المطاف انا على ثقه انه
عندما تمر الميزانيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سوف تستمر المساعدات لاوكرانيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقدم الدوره
الريادي ودور القائد في هذا المجال ويسهل
ذلك العمل على الحلفاء عدد كبير من
الحلفاء يقدم نسبه كبيره من الناتج المح
لي الاجمالي دعما لهذا الغرض شكرا لك
لاريكورد كبير الباحثين في مركز التقدم
الامريكي ومساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق
بولندا تعقد على مدار يومين جلسات منتدى
وارسو الامني في نسخته العاشره يشارك في
المنتدى وزراء دفاع اوروبيون وقاده
عسكريون بالاضافه الى خبراء في مجالات
الامن والطاقه يبحث المشاركون في المنتدى
الوضع في اوكرانيا وكيفيه زياده الدعم
المقدم لها
قالت وزيره خارجيه ايسلندا فورتيس كولبرون
ان منتدى وورسو الامني ناقش استمرار الدعم
لاوكرانيا الى ان تحقق النصر بحسب تعبيرها
وفي مقابله سابقه مع الجزيره اعتبرت
الوزيره ان مسمته النزعه التوسعيه لروسيا
مثيره للقلق وان موسكو لن تتوقف اذا حققت
اهدافها في اوكرانيا بحسب تعبيرها
يمكن القول ان المنتدى بشكل عام يناقش
الدعم المستمر لاوكرانيا الى ان تحقق
النصر هذا فضلا عن الضمانات الامنيه في
المستقبل عن كيفيه هذا الدعم واستخدامه
هناك ممثلون عن اوكرانيا يشاركون في
المنتدى ويشرحون احتياجات بلادهم
والاوكرانيون هم من يتولون اداره
المساعدات التي تحصل عليها بلادهم نعرف ان
روسيا لن تنهي غزوها اذا حققت اهدافها في
اوكرانيا وهذه النزعه التوسعيه لدى روسيا
مقلقه ويجب ان تثير قلق العالم باسره
[موسيقى]
اتهم رئيس وزراء المجلس العسكري في النيجر
علي الامين زين فرنسا بتنفيذ خطه لزعزعه
امن واستقرار النيجر بعد الغاء الاتفاقيات
الامنيه والدفاعيه معها وقال رئيس الوزراء
ان الخطه الفرنسيه تشمل اغتيال وزراء في
الحكومه وشخصيات من شيوخ القبائل لاحداث
اضطرابات امنيه وكذلك تزويد الاعداء
بالسلاح والعتاد على حد تعبيره
قال وزير الداخليه في حكومه المجلس
العسكري بالنيجر محمد تنمبا للجزيره ان
المجلس العسكري وافق على المهله التي
حددها الرئيس الفرنسي لانسحاب قواته من
النيجر نهايه العام واضاف ان الرئيس
ماكرون يخاطب مواطنيه بشان انسحاب قوته من
النيجر ولم يتواصل مع المجلس حتى اللحظه
بشان سحب تلك القوات
حتى نهايه السنه نحن موافقون على مغادرتهم
لكن الرئيس الفرنسي في الحقيقه يخاطب
الفرنسيين هو لا يتحدث الى النيجيريين
عندما تحدث ربما كان يخاطبكم انتم لكنه لم
يخاطبنا رسميا ويقول انه يريد المغادره في
هذه الحاله ما يقوله الرئيس الفرنسي لا
يلزم الا نفسه باختصار نلاحظ انهم يبحثون
عن تاخير للامر اي انهم يعلنون شيئا ولا
ينون فعله
وكانت وزاره الدفاع في النيجر قد اعلنت
مقتل 29 جنديا في هجمات شنها مسلحون على
قوه كانت تغادر منطقه العمليات على الحدود
مع مالي وقالت الوزاره ان الجيش نفذ عمليه
عسكريه الاسبوع الماضي بمنطقه الحدود مع
مالي ضد مسلحي تنظيم الدوله في المنطقه
وبعد مغادره القوات وفي طريق عودتها هوجمت
بسيارات ودراجات مفخخه في شمال غربي منطقه
تباتون واشار الى ان الجيش تمكن من قتل
عشرات من وصفهم بالارهابيين وانه من خلال
رصد اتصالات المسلحين تبين انهم يتلقون
دعما من جهه خارجيه بحسب نص البيان
ينضم الينا من نواكشوط سيد اعمر ولد شيخنا
مدير المركز الاقليمي للابحاث والاستشارات
والخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه سيد ولد
شيخنا في اي سياق تضع اتهامات ياميلي
باريس
اضع هذه الاتهامات في العلاقات السيئه
والمتوتره بين السلطات العسكريه في نياميه
وفرنسا ذلك ان فرنسا تلقت صفعه قويه بهذا
الخروج الذي يوصف من بعض المراقبين ومن
بعض الاوساط في نيابه وفي دول الساحر بانه
مذل ويوصف من قبل بعض فرنسا وبعض اصدقائها
بانه يعني خطوه فرنسيه لاعاده موقع جديد
في المنطقه السلطات العسكريه في ايامها
تعتبر فرنسا تنتقم منهم وتدعم بعض
الجماعات وبعض الانفصاليين المسلحين وانه
ربما تمدهم بالسلاح وتمدهم ببعض العتاد
الذي يساهم في تنفيذ عمليات ولكن في
الحقيقه هذه العمليات في النعمه هي قديمه
هنالك طوارق يشنون حرب منذ سنوات قديمه
على سلطات النيابه وهنالك ايضا جماعات
مسلحه الجهاديه التي تنشط جنوب غرب النيجر
وفي بوركينا فاسو وفي شمال مالي وهي تنسق
بينها وبالتالي يمكن ان تستفيد من التوتر
الحاصل بين فرنسا
ولكن في الحقيقه هي عمليات قديمه ولها
اجنده ترتبط بابعاد شهاديه وبابعاد محليه
انفصاليه طيب التصريحات رئيس الوزراء هل
تؤشر الى ان المرحله المقبله ستشهد زعزعه
لاستقرار فعلا في النيجر
ما نشاهده الان ان هنالك تطور كبير في
العمليات العسكريه
والعمليات الموجهه ضد جيوش ماليو بوركينا
فاسو والنيجر وان هنالك تنسيق بين الدول
الثلاث ماليو بوركينا من اجل التصدي لهذه
العمليات ولا تستبعد هذه العواصم ان يكون
لفرنسا دور ولكن في الحقيقه ايضا هنالك
مشاكل داخليه وتراكمات كبيره واشكالات لا
يمكن القاء اللوم على فرنسا او اي قوه
اقليميه اخرى انما هنالك مشاكل حقيقيه
تتعلق بالانقسام المجتمعي بقضايا جهاديه
وتراكمات وصراع اذني ودعم من قوى دوليه
مختلفه وبالتالي ما تحتاجه المنطقه هو
اعاده ترتيب اوراقها بشكل يخفف شكرا لك من
التدخلات الاجنبيه ولكن ايضا يفسح المجال
للشعوب المنطقه
شكرا سيد اعمر ولد شيخنا مدير المركز
الاقليمي للابحاث والاستشارات والخبير في
الشؤون الافريقيه في نواكشوط شكرا لك
اذا نعود الى جلسه لعزل رئيس مجلس النواب
في الكونغرس الامريكي ونتابع هذه الصور
التي تاتينا مباشره من هناك وانضم الينا
من واشنطن فادي منصور فادي اطلعنا على ما
يجري فعليا في هذه القاعه التي نتابعها
الان مباشره
جلال بحسب
ما يجري الان هناك تصويت داخل مجلس النواب
فرضه ما يوصف باقصى يمين الحزب الجمهوري
من اجل الاطاحه برئيس مجلس النواب
مكرثي وهو الرئيس الجمهوري لمجلس النواب
وذلك على خلفيه ما يصفه الديمقراطيون بحرب
اهليه داخليه ضمن صفوف الجمهوريين وسط
مخاوف من معظم اعضاء الحزب الذين يقفون
وراء رئاسه مكار فيما يحذرون من انه فوضى
وقول اقصى يمين الحزب بان مكارثي اخلى
بوعوده فيما يتعلق بالسياسات الماليه
للبلاد تحديدا فيما يتعلق بسقف الدين ومن
ثم ذهابه الى المقايضه على هذه الوعود في
صفقه يوم السبت مع الديمقراطيين لمنع
الاغلاق الحكومي علما ان رئاسه مكارتي
لمجلس النواب جاءت بعد عمل شاق للغايه
مطلع هذا العام بعد 15 دوره من التصويت
اخفق في اربعه عشره منها قبل ان يصبح
رئيسا لمجلس النواب بحكم الخلافات مع هذا
الجناح وتحديدا بعد تعديلات
ضمنت لاي عضو في مجلس النواب ان يطرح
مساله رئاسته على التصويت كان هناك قبل
هذه الجوله من التصويت تصويت اخر في
محاوله من قبل الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
لمنع حصول التصويت على رئاسته اخفق هذا
المسعى والان ننتظر لنرى ماذا سيحصل في
حال انشقاق اكثر من سته جمهوريه او خمسه
جمهوريين من صفوف الحزب وصوتوا لصالح
لطاحه بمكارثي يكون مكار في عمليا ورئاسته
لم النواب في يد هذا المصير في يد عدد
قليل من اصوات الحزب الديمقراطي وفي حال
اتيح به سنكون امام موقف غير مسبوق
تاريخيا في اروقه الحكم والسياسه والنظام
السياسي الامريكي لم يسبق ان نجحت اي
محاوله في عزل رئيس مجلس نواب وبالتالي
ندخل مرحله من عدم اليقين ولكن هناك بعض
الترتيبات لملء هذا الفراغ لهذا الموقع
الحساس وهو الموقع الثالث من الناحيه
عمليا السلطه التنفيذيه في الحكومه
الامريكيه اي انه ياتي بعد الرئيس ونائب
الرئيس ثم ياتي رئيس مجلس نواب ونحن ننتظر
ان نرى علامه سترسوا هذه النتيجه وان كانت
المؤشرات حتى هذه اللحظه ليست في صالح
مكارثي ولكن ينبغي انتظار النتيجه
النهائيه للتصويت نتابع النتيجه حتى الان
نفادي 184 قالوا نعم
لعزل مكان فيه بينما
175 لا حتى الان مع 0 امتناع في هذه
الجلسه جلسه التصويت على عزل رئيس المجلس
وهو جمهوري كما اسلفت فادي كيفن
اذا 184 بنعم مقابل 175 بلا فادي الدوائر
الرسميه لسيما البيت الابيض كيف تتابع هذا
الجدل في الكونغرس وهذه السابقه في حال
حصلت
التصويت حول هذا الموضوع سبق ان حصل في
التاريخ الامريكي واخره كان في عام 2015
وضد ايضا رئيس مجلس النواب في حينها بينر
ولكن فشل البيت الابيض والكتله
الديمقراطيه كانت حتى قبل بدء هذه الجوله
من التصويت متحده في موقفها بانها ليست
معنيه
بانقاذي هو مد يد العون له هذه مساله
جمهوريه داخليه هذه تعبر عن ما يصفونه
بالحرب الاهليه الداخليه خصوصا ان ماك
كارثي بالنسبه للديمقراطيين اخل بعدد من
الوعود وقام بامور تضر بها الديمقراطيين
والبيت الابيض مباشره اي الرئيس بايدن
اولا تراجعه عن صفقه مع الرئيس بايدن
تتعلق بالانفاق من ناحيه ومن ناحيه ثانيه
فتح المجال امام تحقيقات في الكونجرس قد
تفضي الى محاكمه برلمانيه للرئيس بايدن لا
يرى الديمقراطيون اي مبرر ومن ثم السماح
بوصول الامور الى حافه الاغلاق الحكومي
يوم السبت قبل ان يتم اشترااح صفقه
للاستمرار بتمويل الحكومه حتى الاسبوع
الثالث من شهر نوفمبر تشرين الثاني المقبل
وبالتالي الموقف الذي خرج به الديمقراطيون
هو موقف متحد وراء زعيم الاقليه
الديمقراطيه حكيم جفري ولكن الجمهوري
يحاولون عمليا قدر الامكان حتى اللحظات
الاخيره تعويض النقص في الاصوات التي قد
يحتاجونها لانقاذ رئاسه مجلس النواب بيد
مكارثي من خلال التواصل مع عدد من
الديمقراطيين للتصويت لصالح لصالح بقائه
وقد وقد يامل الجمهوريون ان بعض
الديمقراطيين في بعض الولايات التي قد
تكون في حاله خطر بالنسبه للمرشحين
الديمقراطيين ان عمليا ينتقل هؤلاء من صف
لتصويت مجلس النواب الامريكي على عزل رئيس
المجلس الجمهوري كيفن مكارسي 209 بنعم
و192
بلاه
فادي الى ماذا يؤشر
قوه اذا صح التعبير اقصى اليمين في هذه
الاجراءات التي نشاهدها الان وهذه الجلسه
التي نتابع وقائعها معك في واشنطن لاقصاء
كبن مكارثي وهو جمهوري كما اسلفنا سابقا
نعم جلال بالنسبه في حال نجاح هذا الموضوع
حتى وان واقع وجود هذا التصويت في هذه
اللحظه لا يشير الى نفوذ كتله كبيره داخل
صفوف الحزب الجمهوري هناك نحو احد عشر
صوتا عمليا ممن تمسكوا بفكره عزله داخل
اروقات الحزب الجمهوري قد يتضاءل هذا
العدد من اصل اكثريه 221 جمهوريا في مجلس
النواب وبالتالي تظل هذه الكتله ضئيله لكن
حقيقه ان مكارتي هو من توصل ووافق على هذه
التسويه في يناير الماضي من اجل ان يمسك
بزمام الامور في مجلس النواب كانت تشير في
البدايه الى ضعف موقع ضعف هذا الموقع
والنفوذ السياسي داخل الحزب الجمهوري
وايضا الانقسام السياسي الحاد بما ان احدا
من الجمهوريين لا يمكن ان يراهن على اصوات
ديمقراطيه لصالح مكارثي
رئاسه مجلس النواب توضع في يد حزب
الاكثريه في مجلس النواب وبالتالي هذا
الامر يقع على عاتق الجمهوريين ولكن من
ناحيه اخرى على سبيل المثال يعتبر
الديمقراطيون ان هذا الامر لن يؤدي فقط
الى مساله الفوضى ولكن يشير الى عدميه
داخل الحزب الجمهوري هذه العدميه تمثلت في
التحقيقات التي وافق عليها مكارثي واطلقها
من اجل ربما ايصال بايدن الى محاكمه
برلمانيه دون اي مسوغ كما يقول
الديمقراطيون هذه العدميه اوصلت البلاد
يوم السبت الماضي الى حافه الاغلاق
الحكومي مع التكاليف الضخمه لهذا الموضوع
هذه العدميه ايضا اوصلت في نهايه المطاف
مكارسي ليواجه كتله صغيره داخل حزبه
ولكنها قادره على الاطاحه به ووضع كل
الاجنده التشريعيه في مهب الريح الى حين
التوصل الى تسويه من اين تستمد القوه لهذه
المجموعه كما وصفتها بالصغيره داخل الحزب
الجمهوري من اين تستمد هذه القوه اذا صح
التعبير او هذا النفوذ
هي بالاساس النقطه الاساسيه الاجرائيه
نتيجه الصفقه التي وافق عليها مكارثي من
اجل عمليا الفوز في الجوله الخامسه عشر في
يناير الماضي برئاسه مجلس النواب اي ان
مجلس النواب التام وصوت 15 مره لكي ينجح
في نهايه المطاف مكارس في الوصول ولكن بعد
ان وافق على منح اي عضو في مجلس النواب
وهذه كانت التسويه تجاه هذه الكتله كضمانه
لهم وكسيف يظل مسلطا فوق رقبته في نهايه
المطاف انه في حال حصل خلاف في حال اخلى
بوعوده يستطيع اي عضو ان يدعو للتصويت
للاطاحه به وهذا ما استفادت به هذه الكتله
اقصى اليمين المحافظه داخل الحزب الجمهوري
لتقول هو لم يفي بوعوده وبالتالي نحن في
حل من هذه الصفقه لانه اولا ذهب للتراجع
عن مسؤوليه الماليه ومشكله الدين العام
والمديونيه عجز في الميزانيه التي الضخمه
والتي تفوق قدرتنا على الانفاق وتحملها من
ناحيه ومن ناحيه ثانيه لانه ذهب لاشتراح
صفقه مع الديمقراطيين على حساب الاجنده
التي توافقنا عليها داخل اروقه الحزب
الجمهوري وبالتالي هناك انقسام حاول ان
يلم شمله في انتخابات يناير عندما وصل الى
رئاسه مجلس النواب من خلال هذه الضمانه
الاجرائيه لكن هذه الكتله امسكت بهذه
الضمانه عمليا واستخدمتها ضده طيب فادي
بلغه الارقام ونحن نتابع هذه الارقام على
الشاشه 216 مقابل
109 لا في لغه الارقام كم يحتاج من يريد
عزل مكار في منصبه رئيسا لمجلس النواب
هناك اكثر من سيناريو بطبيعه الحال في حال
صوت جميع الحاضرين فهو يحتاج الى اغلبيه
هذه الاصوات قرابه
عشر صوتا لكن في حال صوت عدد من
الديمقراطيين فقط بالحضور على سبيل المثال
ينخفض العدد المطلوب من اجل الاطاحه به
وبالتالي الامر يتعلق بمعرفه عدد من
سينتهي بهم الامر للتصويت على سبيل المثال
الجوله الماضيه من اجل
المضي في التصويت على الاطاحه به خسر مكار
في ذلك الاجراء بواقع
صوتا ضده
اذا فادي نتابع الان
216 صوتا بنعم مقابل 210 لا وصفر امتناع
حتى الساعه في هذه الجلسه لمجلس النواب
الامريكي الذي يواصل التصويت على عزل رئيس
المجلس كيفن مكارثي فدي هل برزت اي مواقف
سياسيه من شخصيات ربما مؤثره او او نافذه
في كلا الحزبين خاصه في المتعلق بالحزب
الجمهوري
نعم كانت هناك جلسه عمليا صرح بها خلالها
المشرعون الجمهوريون وادلوا بدلوهم بهذا
الشان الكتله التي تريد الاطاحه بمكارتي
كانت واضحه في مواقفها عمليه هو خانه
العهد مرتين فيما يتعلق بالمسؤوليه
الماليه التي اتفقنا عليها ومساله ضبط
والحد من عجز الميزانيه ولكن ايضا الصفقه
التي ذهب اليها في مساله الاغلاق الحكوميه
وبالتالي هو لا يحوز على الثقه بعد الان
في المقابل الكتله الاساسيه للحزب
الجمهوري والاغلبيه الساحقه من الحزب
الجمهوري وقفت وقالت ان ماكارتي يستحق ان
يكون في هذا الموقع انه يدافع عن جنه
الحزب الجمهوري يدافع عن حكم الحزب
الجمهوري داخل مجلس النواب في حين ان ما
تذهب اليه تلك الكتله الصغيره تذهب الى
الفوضى وهي ليست في صالح احد وليست في
صالح الحزب الامه الامريكيه فادي نشرك
معنا وجد وقفه اذا مجلس النواب الامريكيه
يعزل رئيسه من منصبه للمره الاولى في
تاريخ البلاد اذا الان قضي الامر مجلس
النواب الامريكي يعزل رئيسه من منصبه
للمره الاولى في تاريخ البلاد فادي نشرك
معنا وجد وقفه تنضم الينا من البيت الابيض
وجد كيف يتابع البيت الابيض ما حصل في
الكونغرس عزل رئيس مجلس النواب للمره
الاولى في تاريخ البلاد
يعني جلال بالكثير من الترقب حقيقه حدث
تاريخي للمره الاولى كما ذكرت في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده في عام 1910 كانت هناك
ايضا محاوله للاطاحه برئيس مجلس النواب
لكنه نجى منها هذه هي المره الاولى التي
فعلا تتم الاطاحه برئيس مجلس النواب 210
اصوات كانت كافيه للاطاحه به وذلك لتغيب
او عدم تصويت عدد من اعضاء مجلس النواب
كان الموضوع يتطلب 219 صوتا للاطاحه
للاطاحه به سبعه جمهوريين صوتوا لصالح
الاطاحه به
كان هناك صوت جمهوري واحد في حال صوت جميع
اعضاء مجلس النواب سيكون العدد 219 ضد
مقارنه لصاحبه اذا مع تغيب وعدم تصويت عدد
من اعضاء مجلس النواب 110 اصوات كانت
كفيله للاطاحه بمجلس النواب الان الكونغرس
حقيقه حقيقه لا يعلم كيف يمكن مواصله
العمل لان مهام مجلس النواب هو الذي مثلا
يطرح مشاريع القرارات للتصويت تاتي من
مجلس من رئيس مجلس النواب في حال اي من
المشرعين الاداره الامريكيه البيت الابيض
طلب تشريعا ونحن الان امام تشريع مهم جدا
حتى الان لم يوافق عليه مجلس او الكونجرس
بمجلسي وهو تشريع تمويل
مساعدات لاوكرانيا الميزانيه مرت بموافقه
وهذا القرار الذي اتى الان للمره الاولى
في تاريخ امريكا كما ذكرنا يشبه قرارا
عقابيا لمكار في لانه بحسب الجمهوريين
اليمينيين هو خانه العهد
جاء من اجلي واصلا جاء الى الكونجرس
باغلبيه ضعيفه وهو يعتبر احد اضعف رؤساء
مجلس النواب الامريكي بتاريخ الولايات
المتحده جلال اذا البيت الابيض ربما الان
يتوجس من هذه الاطاحه بمجلس برئيس مجلس
النواب بسبب كما ذكرنا مشروع قرار
المساعدات لاوكرانيا التي لم يتم اقراره
حتى الان وهناك ايضا مشروع قرار الميزانيه
برمتها 45 يوما فقط
تمرير هذه الميزانيه لتسيير امور الحكومه
الفيدراليه خلال هذه الفتره لا نعلم ما
الذي سيحدث بالميزانيه برمتها خلال الايام
والاسابيع المقبله ينبغي على مجلس النواب
ان يصوت لرئيس جديد متى وكيف الاجراءات
حقيقه كون ان هذه هي السابقه في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده حتى يمكن ان نقول بان ها
حتى عدد من اعضاء مجلس النواب ربما لا
يعلمونهم ايضا جلال وذلك كما ذكرنا لانها
المره الاولى وكما قلت فعليا بانه الان
يعلن عن شغور في منصب رئاسه مجلس النواب
فادي مسيناريو المتوقع الان ما الاجراءات
التي يجب اتخاذها بعد شهور منصب رئيس مجلس
النواب
مجلس النواب لائحه سريه باسماء خمسه اعضاء
من مجلس النواب يمكن لاحدهم ان يتولى
رئاسه مجلس النواب بالانابه قد يكون على
سبيل المثال النائب سكاليز وهو
زعيم الاغلبيه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب
مكارسي هو كان الرئيس حتى قبل اللحظات قبل
ان يتم خلعه من هذا المنصب وبالتالي يتولى
احد الجمهوريين رئاسه المجلس بالانابه ومن
ثم نتوجه الى انتخابات رئاسه مجلس النواب
مره اخرى يستطيع مكارسي بطبيعه الحال وقد
يحاول الحزب الجمهوري الكتله كتله
الاغلبيه الساحقه في الحزب ان تقف ورائها
لتقول ان ما حصل لا يمثل الحزب بل يمثل
اقليه شارده عن
الرئيسي للحزب فيها اسماء متحالفه مع
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب وتليحاول ان
يبعث برساله في هذا الاطار ولكنها سوف
تكون معركه قاسيه للغايه للغايه سبق وان
شاهدنا ما حصل في يناير الماضي من جولات
تصويت متعدده
وقد يتجه الى محاوله تسويه لانقاذ الحزب
من معركه قاسيه اخرى في محاوله للتوصل الى
اسم قد يتوافق تتوافق عليه اروقه الحزن
الان
حاولت دي رئيسا مؤقت لمجلس النواب
الامريكي اذا فادي الان الاعلان لان
باتريك هنري هو رئيسا مؤقتا لمجلس النواب
الامريكي اذا
اعلان باتريك مكانبي رئيسا مؤقتا لمجلس
النواب الامريكي وجد
ما الذي يفرضه ما حصل اليوم في الكونغرس
وعزل رئيس مجلس النواب ما الذي يفرضه من
ممارسه واداء ربما من اي رئيس
لمجلس النواب مقبل في هذه المرحله من عمر
اداره الرئيس بايدن
يعني هو حقيقه اليوم في البيت الابيض جلال
كانت هناك الكثير من النداءات في هنا في
البيت الابيض خلال الاحاطه الصحفيه
للجمهوريين في مجلس النواب من اجل التعجيل
في تسريع الموافقه على ميزانيه الحكومه
الفيدراليه
الدائمه للعام المالي واربعه وعشرين
هذه كانت نداءات سئل
جونكر بمنسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي عن مصير مقاهي وماذا لو تمت
الاطاحه به بدا
جانكر يعني واثقا من ان الميزانيه سوف
تمرر او بالاحرى المساعدات الخاصه
لاوكرانيا سوف تمرر عفوا ليس الميزانيه
الحكومه الفيدراليه قال نحن واثقون من ان
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين سيمررونها بغض
عن من هو رئيس المجلس النواب اذا ما يهم
الاداره والرئيس الامريكي هو فقط ان يتم
تمرير القرارات المتعلقه بالاداره ساعود
لكما وجد في البيت الابيض وفادي في واشنطن
ينضم الينا من فيرجينيا سيد كليد ويلكوكس
وهو استاذ الحكومه والسياسه الامريكيه في
جامعه جورج تاون سيد كليد كيف تابعت ما
حصل الان في مجلس النواب وعزل رئيسه
مكارثه
الحزب الجمهوري منقسم الى مجموعتين مجموعه
اكبر من الاخرى وهناك مجموعه من المحافظين
وهناك مجموعه راديكاليه من المحافظين التي
تود ان لا تقدم التنازلات بالنسبه الى
الميزانيه وبالنسبه الى الامور الاخرى ان
السيد مكارثي وصل الى منصبه
باكثريه قليله للغايه وفي تصويت بقي حتى
النهايه لانه قدم تنازلات مرتبطه
على الحكومه عامله ولكن هناك انضمام من
قبل هؤلاء الراديكاليين الى الديمقراطيين
المحتمله في الفتره المقبله
نحن نتحدث عن امر كبير لم يحصل من قبل في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المشكله
الرئيسه الان هي ان الحزب الجمهوريه منقسم
للغايه وتطلب الامر جولات متعدده من
التصويت لاختيار السيد مكارثي الذي كان
الخيار المنطقي ما من شخصيه
واضحه المعالم لتولي هذا المنصب وسوف يكون
هناك جدل على مستوى الحزب الجمهوري على
الارجح الحزب الديمقراطي سوف يترك الحزب
الجمهوري يتقاتل فيما بينه وبالتالي
التبعات المباشره هي انه لن يكون لدينا
مجلس نواب عامل بطريقه طبيعيه لفتره وما
تاثيرات هذا الاقتتال كما وصفته في الحزب
الجمهوري على الحزب في استحقاقات مقبله
لسيما الانتخابات الرئاسيه مثلا
بانه سيستمر في هذا الدعم ما مصير كل هذا
في ظل ما حدث
في الحقيقه من المبكر ان نجيب عن هذا
السؤال حيث ان الامور بحاجه الى بعض الوقت
لكي تتجلى ولكن اعتقد ان اداره بايدن سوف
تصل الى طرق تسمح بتمويل اوكرانيا من خلال
ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع يمكن ان تحرك بعض
الاموال ولكنه قد يكون من الصعب بالنسبه
الينا للقيام باي شيء لان النظام الامريكي
مبني على التنازلات بين المؤسسات
الامريكيه للتقدم بتشريعات مجلس النواب
مجلس الشيوخ ورئيس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يقدمون جميعا تنازلات ومجلس
النواب لا يمكنه ان يقدم التنازلات الا في
حال شارك في هذه المفاوضات ان تنجح
اقليه صغيره داخل الحزب الجمهوري في فرض
هذا العزل والتصويت لعزل مكارتي الى ماذا
يؤشر هذا في سياسه الحزب وايضا في
الممارسه
التشريعيه في مجلس النواب
في الحقيقه نحن نتحدث عن وضع خاص الحزب
الجمهوري كان لديه هامش ضيق للغايه
وبالتالي
الاشخاص
المعتدلين ليس لديهم اكثريه للوصول بشخصيه
اما بالنسبه الى المجموعه الصغيره من
الراديكاليين على استعداد
لتركيعه مجلس النواب في حال لم يتمكنوا من
الحصول على ما يريدون هذه لربما طريقه
هؤلاء بالتفاوض اذا ما لم تعطونا ما نريد
لن نسمح لاي شيء ان يحصل ولكن المشكله هي
ان الاكثريه الساحقه من الامه الامريكيه
لا تود نفس الشيء وبالتالي هذه المشكله
شكرا لك السيد كليد ويلكوكس استاذ الحكومه
والسياسه الامريكيه في جامعه جورج تاون في
فرجينيا شكرا لك اذا هذه التغطيه مستمره
لعزل رئيس مجلس النواب الجمهوري في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حسن جامول
يتابع معكم هذه التغطيه الان حسن شكرا
جزيلا لك جلال بالفعل نتابع هذه التغطيه
مشاهدينا
لاعز الكيدن مكارسي رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي
وتعيينري رئيسا مؤقتا له مباشره الى البيت
الابيض مع مراسله الجزيره وجد وقفي
لاستذكار ما الذي حصل في
الاونه الاخيره في النصف ساعه الاخيره
التي سبقت عزل كيفن ماكيرسي وجد
نعم نعم حسن عزل كاظم
لم يكن حقيقه مفاجئا كثيرا
ذلك لانه اضعف رئيس لمجلس النواب في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده تسلم هذا المنصب المنصب
باغلبيه ضئيله وبعد عده محاولات تصويت
كانت معظمها فاشله فقط اخر محاوله تصويت
نجحت وذلك بفضل الاتفاق عقده مع اليمين
المتطرف او المتشدد ضمن الحزب الجمهوري
بعدم تجاوز
المحددات التي تم وضعها له تحديدا من
ناحيه الانفاق والميزانيه ميزانيه الحكومه
الفيدراليه اقرار مجلس النواب ميزانيه
عد في عطله نهايه الاسبوع التي مرت كانت
هي النقطه حقيقه التي اصابت مستقبله
السياسي في ومنصبه كرئيس لمجلس النواب في
مقتل هو
نقض عهده مع اليمينيين المتشددين الذين
كان لهم الفضل في وصوله الى مجلس النواب
وبالتالي قدم نائب جمهوري جيتس مشروع
القرار امس طرحه على مجلس النواب وتم
التسريع في التصويت عليه اليوم اليوم ليتم
بالفعل عزل كين مقر في كرئيسا لمجلس
النواب للمره الاولى في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده ومباشره تعيين رئيس مجلس نواب
بالانابه بالنسبه للاجراءات حقيقه كون هذه
هي المره الاولى فاعضاء مجلس النواب ما
زالوا مجتمعين لوضع اليات من اجل التسريع
في التصويت على رئيس جديد لمجلس النواب
غيتس الذي تقدم بمشروع القرار ادلى
بتصريحات بعد لعزل مقاهي واكد بانه لا
يعتزم الترشح لرئاسه مجلس النواب واكد بان
كافين مقر في نقض العهود التي قطعها مع
الجمهوريين
المتشددين اذا اذا اردنا ان نسال هنا كيف
تم عزل كيفن
قلتي بانها يعني لم تكن مفاجاه كثيرا ولكن
الامر يشكل سابقه اما داخل الكونجرس كيف
كانت خريطه المواقف وخريطه الاصوات داخل
الكونغرس والتي انتهت بالاطاحه بكيفن
مكانثي من منصبه
نعم
216 صوتا صوتوا او عضوا في مجلس النواب
صوتوا ضد مقارتي لصالح عازل مقال فيه هناك
ثمانيه جمهوريين ثمانيه من داخل الحزب
الجمهوري صوتوا ضد مقرتي وهذا حقيقه مؤشر
حسن على
الانقسام داخل الحزب الجمهوري الديمقراطي
في معظمهم صوتوا ضد مقاعد فيه كونه من
الحزب الجمهوري وهذا متوقع ولكن
الجمهوريون الثمانيه الذين صوتوا ضد مقر
في هو كان يعول على ان لا يصوتوا لصالح
هذه ولكنهم فعلوا فعلوا ذلك وعكس رغبه
مقرفه حقيقه تيار اذا انجاز التعبير
التيار للترامبي ما زال يؤثر على مجلس
النواب حسن جيت صاحب مشروع القرار الذي
بناء عليه تم اليوم عزل
هو من مؤيدي وانصار الرئيس السابق دانول
ترامب وعدد كبير من الجمهوريين داخل الحزب
الجمهوري ما زال مع الرئيس من انصار
الرئيس دانول ترامب نحو ثلث او اكثر من
الجمهوريين ما زالوا من انصار الرئيس
السابق دانون ترامب لذلك نقول كان متوقعا
عزله ولكن حقيقه كونها سابقه ما كان لاحد
ان يتخيل ولا حتى البيت الابيض حسن يعني
اليوم جون كير من مجلس الامن القوميه خلال
الاحاطه يعني استبعد جميع الاسئله التي
طرحت عليه بشان مصير مقر في السياسي وقال
هذا امر افتراضي ولن اتحدث بشانه ولكنه
بدا واثقا مثلا من مشروع قرار ما زال لم
يصوت عليه الكونجرس مجلس النواب والشيوخ
وهو مشروع قررت
لاوكرانيا هذا القرار ما زال لم يحظى باي
تقدم حتى الان ومع الاطاحه بمقال فيه اذا
كان رئيس مجلس النواب الجديد من مؤيدي
الرئيس ترامب قد لا يوافق على مشروع
القرار حقيقه كل شيء ما زال ضبابيا وغير
معروف مصيره ذلك لانه كما ذكرت حسن هي
المره الاولى
من البيت الابيض لنتابع ايضا مع فادي
منصور مراسل الجزيره في واشنطن فادي اذا
كانت يعني لا نريد ان نقول بهذه السهوله
ولكن بهذه السرعه
تم الاطاحه
هل بامكان الجمهوريين اذا ان يتفقوا على
بديل
لرئيس مجلس النواب
نعم هناك عده عوامل ادت الى هذه النتيجه
حسن اولا الجانب الاجرائي المتعلق بمنح
مكار في خصومه من الجمهوريين وان كانوا
اقليه الحق في التصويت على الاطاحه به
وهذا ما استخدموه اليوم النقطه الثانيه ان
مكارتي كان واثقا حتى اللحظه الاخيره من
انه سيتجاوز هذه العقبه لكن حساباته عمليا
لم تكن صائبه والنقطه الاهم ان الحزب
الديمقراطي بعث برساله واضحه انه ليس
معنيا بانقاذ مكارثي وبان ما يحصل هو حرب
اهليه داخليه داخل الحزب الجمهوري على
وصفهم الان مكانري الذي عمليا عين في هذا
موقع موقع رئاسه مجلس النواب او القائم
باعمال رئيس مجلس النواب هو من اشد
المؤيدين
هو من قياده الحزب الجمهوري في مجلس
النواب هو رئيس اللجنه الشؤون الماليه في
المجلس وسبق له يوم امس ان اعرب عن موقف
مؤيد لمكارتي وصفه بانه الزعيم الثابت
لمجلس النواب وبان البلاد تحتاجه طالما ان
الجانب اذا صح التعبير الذي
دمر الهيكل واسقط الهيكل على رؤوس
الجمهوريين هم هؤلاء الاقليه فان الكتله
الاساسيه داخل الحزب الجمهوري التيار
الرئيسي الذي يريد ان يبعث برساله بانه
قادر على الحكومه وبانه يفهم معنى الحكم
بانه يريد ان يدافع عن مصالح الامريكيين
سيحاول بطبيعه الحال ان يتوافق على مرشح
سواء كان هذا المرشح مكارثي مره اخرى او
اي مرشح اخر يبقى هذا السؤال معلق واذا
كان اصلا يستطيع ان يحشد اصوات الكافيه
لتجنب الكاس المر التي شهد الحزب في يناير
الماضي عندما اضطر للتصويت خمسه عشره جوله
من اجل الوصول بمكارتي الى سنه رئاسه مجلس
النواب ام يشترح عمليا نوع من الصفقه مع
الديمقراطيين للحصول على بعض الاصوات
مقابل بعض التنازلات هناك سيناريوهات
متعدده في هذا الاتجاه
قلت بان مكارتي لم يعني لم يكن متوقعا
وكان الى حد ما مرتاحا
لوضعه كرئيس لمجلس النواب لكن على ماذا
كان يراهن ولماذا خسر هذا الرهان
هو كان متحديا اذا صح التعبير عندما قدم
مشروع القرار من اجل التصويت على الاطاحه
به هو رحب بهذه المعركه ومن ثم صرح باكثر
من موقع بانه لا يعول على الديمقراطين
وبالتالي كان يضع صوره الزعيم القادر على
التغلب على هذه المعركه هل فعلا كان لديه
ما يكفي من المعطيات والارقام الداخليه في
الحزب ليكون بهذا الارتياح وبهذا التحدي
ام هذه الجزء من اللعبه اداره اللعبه
السياسيه حتى اللحظه الاخيره لكن اعتقد
عندما خرج الديمقراطيون بشكل واضح وقالوا
انهم يقفون وراء زعيمهم حكيم الجفري بات
من الواضح ان هناك مشكله كبيره يواجهها
مكارثي ومن ثم عندما حصل التصويت الاول اي
التصويت على
قدما في هذا المشروع مشروع التصويت على
الاطاحه بمكاثه وعندما خسر مكارثي الاصوات
هناك تحديدا 11 صوتا جمهوريا بدات الصوره
قاتمه بالنسبه اليه وهو ما ادى في نهايه
المطاف الى سقوطه ربما كان يعول على بعض
الاصوات ما توصف بالاصوات المعتدله في
الحزب الديمقراطي التي قد تكون لديها
معارك انتخابيه قاسيه في الانتخابات
المقبله وبالتالي قد تحتاج الى اصوات بعض
الجمهوريين ويمكن من خلال التصويت له ان
تقدم نفسها على انها قادره على التسويه
قادره على المقايضه قادره على مد اليد الى
الجهه المقابله لكن كل رهاناته في نهايه
المطاف السقطت وبحسب التاريخ حتى هذه
اللحظه من الواضح كما ان رئاسته عمليا
قامت على هذه الاقليه في نهايه المطاف
ورغبتها بالتسويه كانت من موقع القوه رغم
ضاله اعدادها هنا اقصى اليمين في هذه
الحزب فان رئاسته في نهايه المطاف سقطت
بعد ان سحبت هذه الاقليه دعمها لهم هذه
منصور ابقى معنا في واشنطن
ونبقى في العاصمه الامريكيه ينضم الينا
بروسفاين مساعد نائب وزير العدل الامريكي
سابقا والخبير القانوني سيد بروس فاين
اولا
ما هي التداعيات برايك لهذا الحدث او لهذه
السابقه في مجلس النواب الامريكي
هذا يعني انه لدينا فتره مفتوحه من الفوضى
تقريبا على مستوى مجلس النواب الذي شلل
تقريبا لانه هو من دوني رئيسا لمجلس
النواب ان الزراعه التشريعيه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا يمكنها ان تمضي قدما
وفي الفتره الراهنه ما من شخصيه واضحه
لخلافه السيد ماكارتي ما من احد تطوع
للترشح لهذا المنصب لاستبدال السيد مكارتي
وهناك انعدام لليقين بالنسبه الى دوري
الديمقراطيين هل يدعمون مرشحا جمهوريا هل
يمكن ان يقدم تنازلات بالنسبه الى اسم
الشخصيه الجديده هل سوف تصر الشخصيه
الجديده على انه اذا ما كان هذا النائب
يود ان يتولى رئاسه مجلس النواب سوف يقدم
تنازلات كل هذه الامور مجهوله ومن غير
المرجح ان تحلى في القريب العاجل وهذا
يعني انه لمده اسبوع من الزمن او اكثر
مجلس النواب في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لن يعمل بشكل جيد بالنسبه الى
قدره الحزب الجمهوري على السيطره على مجلس
النواب للعام 2024 اذا ما اخذنا هذا
المنظور الوضع صعب للجمهوريين لانه ليس
باستطاعاتهم ان يؤمنوا استطباب الامور على
مستوى مجلس النواب وهناك فوضى وفقط عددا
قليلا من الجمهوريين حرك هذا
الامر وبالتالي يقول الناس عند ذلك
الجمهوريون ليس باستطاعتهم ان يتولوا زمام
المبادره وهذا يؤثر لربما على الاكثريه في
العام 2024
طيب بالنسبه للجمهوريين
تحدثت
عن انهم ليس لديهم مرشح واضح الان ماذا عن
باترك ماك هنري هل يمكن ان يكون بديل
رئيس مجلس النواب بالانابه لهذه المرحله
المؤقته ولكنه ليس بشخصيه التي يمكن ان
تتبوا هذا المنصب لا اعتقد ان باستطاعته
ان يحصل على الاكثريه والتصرف على مجلس
النواب هو اساسي بعد القرار الذي تم
تمريره يوم الاحد وهناك فكره الاغلاق
الحكومي تلوح في الافق اذا هذه المساله
اساسيه جمع الاصوات على مستوى الحزب
الجمهوري في غضون 45 يوم من اجل تمويل
الحكومه لكي تتفادى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اغلاقا حكوميا كل ذلك يعني ان
الضروره القصوى هي توصلي الى حلول ولكن
ذلك غير مرجح بالنظر الى مواقف حزب
الديمقراط والحزب الجمهوري 45 يوما ليست
بالفطره الطويله بالنظر الى الهوه الواسعه
بين الطرفين في حزب الجمهوريه
والقصيد
لكن حاجه حاجه البيت الابيض حاجه الاداره
الامريكيه لتفادي الاغلاق
والتصويت على الميزانيه السنويه وليس
ميزانيه مؤقته كما حصل هذه الحاجه
الا تفرض على الديمقراطيين ان يدخلوا هذه
اللعبه
ويعني
يرشحوا او يدعموا مرشحا ولو كان جمهوريا
من اجل تمرير هذه الميزانيه
هذا صحيح انت على حق وهذه حجه قويه وخصوصا
اذا ما حث الرئيس بايدن بصفته رئيسا
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه الحزب
الديمقراطي على التحالف مع الحزب الجمهوري
للمضي قدما بشان هذه المشاريع وهذه
التشريعات ولكن السياسه هي لعبه غريبه
للغايه اذا ما ظن الحزب الديمقراطي على
سبيل المثال ان وقف العمل على مستوى مجلس
النواب يمكن ان يلوم عليه الناس في
الولايات المتحده الحزب الجمهوري لربما
ايضا يقولون حتى الاغلاق الحكومي اذا ما
تمكنا من لوم الجمهوريين عليه لربما
الديمقراطيون يستمرون في ذلك اذا هناك عمل
طبعا يمكن ان يتم مع المعتدلين في الحزب
الجمهوري لتفادي اي ازمه اغلاق حكومه نعم
يمكن ان يحصل ولكن اذا ما اظن
الديمقراطيون ان باستطاعتهم ان يلوموا
الجمهوريين بسبب هذه الازمه لربما يتركون
الامور تسير كما هي طب اذا عدنا الى
الجمهوريين سيدي
وتحدثنا عن تلك الاقليه او عن المتشددين
الذين في نهايه المطاف نجحوا بعزل رئيس
مجلس النواب
هؤلاء هل بالضروره هم من اشد مؤيدي الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب
[موسيقى]
انها هناك تداخل كبير ولكنه ليس تداخلا
كاملا اعتقد ان الجمهوريين الذين قرروا ان
يتركوا او
يوقفوا الدعم لمكار ثقالوا بشكل متكرر ان
السيد مكارسي تقدم بوعود ولكنه لم يحترم
ما قاله ولذلك نتحدث هنا عن عدائيه شخصيه
تجاه شخص السيد مكارثي وليس
التصاقا بالرئيس ترامب طبعا الرئيس ترامب
هو لديه حمله خاصه به لا اعتقد ان هذه
المشكله يمكن ان تحلى من خلال وضع ترامب
جانبا اعتقد ان هذه المشكله مرتبطه
ارتباطا وثيقا بشخصيه السيد مكارسي
وطريقته بالتصرف
كلا الطرفين ولذلك وصل الى هذه النتيجه
اود الاشاره الى
ما يظهر على شاشتنا من تصريح للنائب
الديمقراطي جاري كولولي الذي قال بانه
يتم اجتماع او سيجتمع اعضاء الحزبين كلهم
على حده يوم الاربعاء المقبل من اجل البحث
في
السيناريوهات القادمه سيدي بلوس فاين كما
ان الميزانيه مهمه بالنسبه
للديمقراطيين وربما ربما نقول
يدفعهم ذلك الى
التحدث مع المعتدلين الجمهوريين ايضا
اين هي مصلحه الجمهوريين في ان يبقوا
الوضع في مجلس النواب كما هو عليه من حاله
عدم اليقين وهم على ابواب انتخابات ويلام
على اغلاق حكومي
الحوافز بالنسبه الى الحزب الجمهوريه يمكن
ان تظهر للتفاوض مع الحزب الديمقراطي لكي
يقولوا للشعب الامريكي ان الجهود تتم
بموافقه الحزبين ويحب الشعب الامريكي ان
يرى التعاون بين الحسبين وخصوصا اذا ما
كان هناك قرارات مصريه من مثل الاطاحه
برئيس مجلس النواب للقيام بالعمل كالمعتاد
على مستوى مجلس النواب ولكن المساله
الرئيسه هي هل الحزب الديمقراطي سوف يكون
على استعداد للتواصل مع الحزب الجمهوري
لتامين سير العمل هذا هو السؤال المبهم في
المرحله الراهنه اعتقد ان الانقسام يبدو
انه يظهر بين السيد
زعيم الاقليه ورئيسه مجلس النواب السابقه
بيلوسي قالت انها ضد هذه المحاوله لعزل
مكارتي وهي حضرت ولكنها لم تصوت لصالح
الاطاحه بالسيد بكارتي على عكس زعيم
الاقليه الذي هو متشدد بنسبه الى هذا
الموضوع اذا هناك انقسام ايضا في صفوف
الحزب الديمقراطي بالنسبه الى جاهزيتهم
للانضمام الى الجمهوريين في جهد بين
الحزبين بالنسبه الى الميزانيه والحكومه
وسير الاعمال على مستوى في غرفتي مجلس
النواب ومجلس الشيوخ بالنسبه الى العام
2024 نشير الى ان النائب الديمقراطي الجري
كونولي وصف الجمهوريين بانهم في موقف صعب
وانهم يحاولون العثور على شخص يمكنه ان
يحصل على الاغلبيه سيدي بروست بصفتك خبيرا
قانونيا ومساعد لنائب وزير العدل الامريكي
ايضا سابقا اود ان اسالك عن
الجانب القانوني في هذا الموضوع الان
السيناريو كيف يجب ان يسير داخل مجلس نواب
وماذا عن وجود رئيس مؤقت ماذا يعني ذلك
اذا كنت تقول بان شللا سيصيب عمل المجلس
الحقيقه على المستوى الدستوري وبالنسبه
الى الجانب القانوني يمكن مجلس النواب ان
يغير اللوائح الخاصه به في اي وقت على مر
السنوات الماضيه منذ العام
1994 تم تغيير الاوائح المرتبطه برئاسه
مجلس النواب بطريقه من الطرق
للقيام
بتخفيض صلاحيات رئيس مجلس النواب بمشاركته
باللجان واللجان الفرعيه وتسهيل ايصال
مشاريع القوانين والتشريعات
للطرح امام المجلس حتى في خلال الشهور
وذلك يتم من خلال اكثريه بسيطه اما في
الاجل القريب والامد القريب حتى في غياب
رئيسا لمجلس النواب وهذا الشعور ومن دون
تشريعات جديده لدينا نافذه 45 يوما
بالنسبه الى الحكومه وعمل الحكومه ونتحدث
عن وقت ضروريا لتحديد شخصيه لمجلس انور في
خلاله ولكن بالنسبه الى امر كان مطروحا
اثناء رئاسه مكارتي لمجلس النواب في حال
خفضنا صلاحيات رئيس مجلس النواب المساله
تصبح اقل اهميه ان يكون هناك مجلس رئيس
مجلس نواب منذ سنوات بعيده رئيس مجلس
النواب لم يكن لديه صلاحيات قويه واللجان
واللجان الفرعيه هي التي كانت تتركز بين
ايديها السلطه ولكن كما سبق واسلفت
اللوائح تتغير ويمكن ان تتغير بالنظر الى
الظروف الراهنه
ستبقى معنا
من واشنطن وننتقل الى نيويورك مع محمد
الاسطوحي الكاتب الصحفي المختص في شان
الامريكي السيد محمد
كيف قرات هذا التطور داخل الحزب الجمهوري
وايضا بتداعياته على الوضع العام في
الولايات المتحده على اعتاب الانتخابات
بدا فترته كرئيس لمجلس النواب ضعيفا
للغايه بمعنى انه جاء ومعه اغلبيه ضئيله
جدا
221 مقعد
وفارق ضئيل يجعله
رهينه لمشيئه مجموعه قليله من الجمهوريين
المتشددين هو امضى 15 جوله في الانتخابات
لكي يحصل على مقعده لانه كان كل مره يقدم
تنازلا جديدا لتلك المجموعه من المتشددين
بحيث انه وصل في النهايه الى انه سمح لهم
انه عضو واحد فقط منهم يمكنه ان يقدم طلبا
لعزله من رئاسه مجلس النواب هذا في حد
ذاته يعطي مؤشرا الى انه كان عليه ان يقدم
العديد من التنازلات وهو في النهايه ما
دفع ثمنه الان
في كل الاحوال ايا كان رئيس مجلس النواب
من الجمهورين في هذه الحاله سوف يعاني ما
يعاني منه الان كبن مكارسي
2015 اضطر للتقاعد من منصبه واعتزال العمل
السياسي لانه وجد نفسه في موقف مشابه
وهو الذي صار بعدها رئيسا لهيئه موظفي
البيت الابيض الامريكي قدم ايضا مقترحا
لعزله وان كان لم يتم التصويت عليه في
وقتها فهذا وضعه في موقف ضعيف للغايه الذي
اعقبه ايضا وجد نفسه في موقف صعب لا يتمكن
من خلاله ان يمارس مهام عمله بطريقه صحيحه
فتقاعد ايضا من عمله الان كيفن مكارسي
يواجه نفس المشكله ومن سياتي بعده سيكون
عليه انه اما ان يتبع المجموعه القليله من
المتشددين الذين يريدون فرض اجندتهم
الخاصه او انه
سيكون امر مثير ان نرى من سياتي رئيسا
لمجلس النواب كيف يحاول العوده مره اخرى
لمنصبه وان كنت اراه قد تعرض للكثير من
الاهانات خلال الفتره السابقه لا ادري اذا
كان لديه الرغبه في العوده مره اخرى سمعت
ان هناك عديدا من الجمهوريين اعضاء المجلس
يحولون دفعه لوضعه اسمه مره اخرى هذا
معناه انه سيمر مر به من قبل في يناير
الماضي عندما حاول ان يتولى هذا المنصب
الذي يعتبر زعيم الاغلبيه الجمهوريه ربما
يكون محبوبا حتى من قبل المتشددين
الذي قدم طلب عزل كامل مكارسي قال انه
يدعمه كرئيس للمجلس ويريده ان ياتي لهذا
المنصب
لكن
يعاني من السرطان ويمر الان بفتره علاجيه
صعبه لا اعتقد انه سوف يرحب بهذا المنصب
في هذا الوقت الحالي فلا ندري ان كان
سيقبل به في كل الاحوال الجمهوريين لديهم
مشكله لان ياتوا بالشخص البديل
وايا كان هذا البديل كما ذكرت سيكون عليه
ان يواجه المعضله الصعبه كيف يدير مجلسا
به اغلبيه ضئيله للغايه بما يضع المجلس
ككل
رهينه لمجموعه قليله من الاصوات هنا هنا
ناتي الى دور الديمقراطيين اذا هل يمكن ان
يستغلوا بشكل او باخر ضعف الجمهوريين
ويدخل على الخط
من اجل ايجاد شخصيه
يوافقون عليها هم مع مجموعه من الجمهوريين
ويمرروا الميزانيه كما يريدون
كان هذا ربما سؤالا مطروحا من خلال موقفهم
بشان كيف المقاسين دعنا نقول انه كيف
المقاطي خسر مقعده اليوم ومنصبه كرئيس
للمجلس لانه فعل الشيء الصحيح من وجهه نظر
الديمقراطيين وهو انه حاول ان يبقي
الحكومه مفتوحه هذا ما اراده الديمقراطيون
واغلبيه الجمهوريين لكن هذا الشيء الصحيح
من وجهه نظرهم لم يكن كافيا لانقاذ موقفه
امام تمرد الجمهوريين عليه وهم لم يدعموه
في هذا الموقف كان من الممكن ببساطه لعدد
منهم ان يمتنع حتى عن التصويت كان هذا
الامتناع عن التصويت كافيا لكي يبقي مكان
المقاطع على مقعده فهم ضحوا به لانهم
يرونه في النهايه هذا هو الرجل الذي فتح
تحقيقات بشان عزل جو بايدن استجابه ايضا
للمتشددين هذا هو الرجل الذي يخالف ما
يقولون انه الاتفاق الذي عليه مع الرئيس
بايدن بشان الانفاق في
الصفقه التي تم التوصل اليها بشان رفع سقف
الدين هذه كلها امور تجعل الديمقراطيين
غير راغبين في مساعدته ولكن من يساعدون
اذا هذه هي المشكله
التي اود ان اسالك عنها طيب اذا كان
مكارسي
يعني لم يساعدوه
ولم يكفهم انه
مشي معهم
بموضوع الميزانيه ولو المؤقته طيب من
لديهم من الجمهوريين الذين يمكن ان
يساعدوه او على ماذا يراهنون على اي شخصيه
من الممكن ان يراهنوا على اي شخصيه اكثر
اعتدالا او اقرب الى الوسط لكن المشكله في
الثقافه السياسيه الامريكيه في اللحظه
الحاليه هي التي قتلت كابل مكارسي ويمكن
ان تقتل اقصد سياسيا اي شخصيه تحاول ان
تفعل الشيء الصحيح وهو التفاهم مع الحزب
الاخر مجرد ان يتفاهم رئيس للمجلس مع
الديمقراطيين وان يعتمد عليهم في تمرير اي
سياسات في ثقافه القاعده الجمهوريه الان
هذه خيانه عظمى لانهم يعتبرون ان
الديمقراطيين في خصوصا ونحن في سنه
انتخابيه هم يهاجمونهم بشكل دائم هم
يتهمونهم احيانا بانهم يتصرفون بطريقه غير
امريكيه ولا يعبرون عن مصالح الولايات
المتحده فكيف يمكن للقاعده الجمهوريه ان
تقبل برئيس لمجلس النواب يخضع او يعتمد في
استمراريته على التحالف مع نسبه من
الديمقراطيين هذه جريمه سياسيه قاتله لاي
شخص الجمهوريه في اللحظه الحاليه وهذا ما
ربما يجعل من الصعب على اي شخص يتم القدوم
اليه الان ليست فقط لان الديمقراطيين لا
يريدون التعاون مع الرئيس الجديد للمجلس
ولكن لانه سيجد من الصعوبه ان يعتمد على
مجموعه من الحزب الديمقراطي المعارض في
القاء على منصبه او تمرير السياسات التي
يتفقون عليها هي مشكله بالاساس في الثقافه
السياسيه التي تسود الولايات المتحده
حاليا
والجمهوريون في المقابل لا يبدو انهم
قادرون على الاتفاق على شخصيه في الوقت
الحاضر لتحل محل كيف اذا ما هو سيناريو او
الى اين تتجه على الاقل الكونجرس او الوضع
التشريعي وحتى موضوع الميزانيه المهدده
الحكومات او المؤسسات الحكوميه بالاغلاق
الى اين تتجه كل هذه المشاكل
من خلال ما ذكرته لك انا اعتقد سواء استمر
مكارتي او ذهب وجاء بديل مشكله الميزانيه
ستبقى عالقه وسيفا مسلطا على اي شخصيه
قادمه ما هي التنازلات التي يمكنه تقديمها
اعتقد انه يعني انا استمعت الى الضيفه
السابق وهو يلوم الديمقراطيين على انهم لم
يتعاونوا او يتحالفوا مع مقرتي التحالف
بشان ماذا يعني ما يريده الجمهوريون الان
هو اولا تقديم الاموال كامله لبناء الجدار
العازل على حدود المكسيك هذا يرفضه
الديمقراطيون بشكل كامل وحتى دونالد ترامب
بالمناسبه وكان معه اغلبيه جمهوريه في
بدايه حكمه لم يتمكن من تمرير ذلك ولم
يتمكن من بناء الجدار على مدى اربع سنوات
فكيف ياتي الديمقراطيون الان ليساعدوا
الجمهوريون الجمهوريين في ذلك الجمهوريون
يريدون ايضا وقف او انا اقصد المجموعه
المتشدده منهم التي نتحدث عنها يريدون
وقفا كاملا لمساعده اوكرانيا في الميزانيه
هذا ايضا ما يرفضه الديمقراطيون بل وترفضه
الاغلبيه بين الجمهوريين فهل يتحالفون
معهم لتمرير ذلك المشكله في قضايا سياسات
خلافيه عميقه تجعل من الصعب على
الديمقراطيين ان يقدموا تنازلات بشانها بل
وعلى نسبه كبيره من الجمهورين ايضا ان
تتفق عليها وبالتالي هذه المجموعه من
الجمهوريين المتشددين تجعل رئيس المجلس
رهينه لديهم ومعه الحزب الجمهوري بل ومجلس
النواب الامريكي باكمله ومن يعني اذا كان
الامر كذلك ولا احد بامكانه ان يقدم
تنازلات في سنه
انتخابيه هل نحن امام شلل سيصيب الادارات
الامريكيه
عندما جاء مجلس النواب
يقترب تماما من المناصفه بين الحزبين
وباغلبيه ضئيله جدا لصالح الجمهوريين هذا
كان في حد ذاته مؤشرا لشلل قادم لانه انا
ذكرت جون بينر كرئيس للمجلس 2015
من بعده هؤلاء عانوا كثيرا من هذه المعضله
في التعامل مع ما كان يسمى بحزب الشاي
دعنا نعود الى ما يسمى بحزب الشاي الذي
جاء بمجموعه من المتشددين الى مجلس النواب
الامريكي جاؤوا بافكار متشدده للغايه
متطرفه في افكارها عن الميزانيه عن
الانفاق عن البرامج الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه عن السياسه الخارجيه هذه كلها
امور رغم انها تعتبر حتى داخل الحزب
الجمهوري لا تعبر عن القاعده العريضه ولكن
بما ان هناك اغلبيه ضئيله في المجلس
للجمهوريين فانه حتى هذه الاغلبيه لا
تستطيع ان تمرر اي سياسات لانها في
النهايه لا تستطيع ان تبتعد كثيرا عن تلك
المجموعه القليله من المتشددين داخل الحزب
فالسناريو القادم انا لا اعتقد انه هذا
المجلس يمكنه على مدى تلك الدوره
البرلمانيه ان يواصل دوره بشكل طبيعي
سيكون هناك ذلك الصراع الدائم ربما ينجحون
في انتخاب رئيس جديد للمجلس ايا كان هذا
الاسم في الرئيس القادم ولكنه سيكون في
موقف ضعيف ايضا هل سيقدم تنازلات لتلك
المجموعه المتشدده وهذه اذا استطاع ان
يقدم تلك التنازلات هل سيقنع الاغلبيه ولا
اقول حتى الديمقراطيين هل سيقنع بقيه
الجمهوريين من الاغلبيه الجمهوريه انه
يسيرون في هذا الاتجاه مع هذه السياسات
المتشدده يجب ان تلاحظ شيئا مهما مع هذه
السنه الانتخابيه هناك عدد كبير من هؤلاء
الاعضاء الجمهوريين نجحوا في مقاطعات
في ولايات تميل للديمقراطيين ونجح بعضهم
في مقاطعات فاز بها في الانتخابات السابقه
معنى هذا الكلام انه اذا ما اتخذ سياسات
تميل بشكل كبير للمتشددين داخل الحزب فانه
قد يخسر مقعده في الانتخابات القادمه هذا
يضع حتى هؤلاء الجمهوريين في موقف صعب في
الفتره القادمه على مدى العام القادم ابقى
معنا السيد محمد السطوحي من نيويورك
لننتقل الى فادي منصور من جديد في واشنطن
ومتابعه للمواقف الصادره في العاصمه
الامريكيه ازاء هذا التطور
فادي
نعم حسن ما هو السؤال نعم سالتك عن اخر
المواقف الصادره في واشنطن في ضوء هذا
التطور الذي يعتبر سابقه في تاريخ مجلس
النواب الامريكي
السؤال هو من سيكون في موقع رئيس مجلس
النواب وهل يمكن للجمهورين ان يتوافقوا
على هذا الامر خصوصا ان مكار في غادر
المجلس جيت غادر المجلس وهناك انباء عن
انه لن يكون هناك مساعي للتصويت بطبيعه
الحال على ملء هذا المنصب منصب رئيس مجلس
نوابه التالي هناك سيناريوهات مختلفه
ينبغي للديمقراطيين ان يجتمعوا وينبغي
للجمهوريين ان يجتمعوا واما ان يتوصل
الحزب الجمهوري بمفرده الى تسويه على مرشح
اخر قد يصر على البقاء
السياسيه لهذه المعركه خصوصا بعد المخاض
الطويل منذ يناير حتى هذه اللحظه والرجل
لم يكمل تسعه اشهر في منصبه او ان يتفق
على خيار بديل وبما ان جيتس والكتله
الصغيره التي كانت معه هي التي
قد يكون بيدها على الاقل مفتاح للانتخابات
المقبله خصوصا الى انه هو بعث برسائل
النائب الجمهوري بانه قد يقبل بشخص مثل
وهو
مسؤول الانضباط او التنظيم داخل الحزب
الجمهوري في مجلس النواب الاسم هنا هاوس
ويب او صوت مجلس النواب اي هو الذي عمليا
منصبه يؤكد على الانضباط يؤكد على وقوف
اعضاء الحزب في مجلس النواب وراء الاجنده
التشريعيه سلوكهم تسويطهم وما الى هنالك
لكن امر كان قال بانه يقف وراء مكار في
الشخص الاخر الذي سماه غيث هو رئيس
الاغلبيه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب النائب
ستيف سكاليز ولكن هو ايضا قال انه يدعم
مكارثي وايضا يمر بمرحله
صعبه ولكن على الاقل هذين اسمين طرحهما
جيت في هذا الاطار وايضا الحزب الديمقراطي
الذي كان في يناير الماضي وقف صفا موحدا
وصوت لصالح زعيمه حكيم جفري ولم يصوت
لمكارثي ولم ينقذ مكار فيه من براثن اقصى
اليمين في الحزب الجمهوري يقول حتى هذه
اللحظه انه سوف يصوت لحكيم جفري لكن الان
بعدما حصل الحزب الديمقراطي لا شك لديه
صوت على طاوله على طاوله المفاوضات وسنرى
اذا كان مستعدا لاستخدام هذه الورقه
للتفاوض مع الجمهوريين على عدد من القضايا
الاساسيه لانجاح مرشح ما جمهوري بمعزل عن
اصوات هذه الكتله الصغيره التي اطاحت
بمكار في خصوصا ان التعاون بين الحزبين
حصل في السابق على الاجنده التشريعيه سواء
المواز السابقه حصل في مساله التشريع فيما
يتعلق بتمويل اعاده بناء البنيه التحتيه
مساله ديمقراطي على دعم التكنولوجيا
واشباه الموصلات مع كل مع كل المحاذير
الحزبيه المرتبطه بذلك ولكن السيناريوهات
مفتوحه في اكثر من اتجاه وينبغي ان ننتظر
في الاساس لنرى الديناموكيا داخليه للحزب
الجمهوري سواء تمسكت بمكارتي او ذهبت الى
مرشح اخر قد يجنب الحزب معركه قاسيه اخرى
وان كانت الاجنده التشريعيه غير واضحه في
هذا الاطار هل سوف تميل الى اقصى اليمين
ام ان هذه الكتله الصغيره التي قادها جيس
بعد ان اثبتت وجهه نظرها قد لا بالضروره
تقف عائقا مره اخرى امام ترشيح شخص اخر
غير خصوصا ان مكارتي سبقه وان قال بان ما
يقوم به غيس هو مس شخصيه لا تتعلق بالاساس
في السياسه وفق رؤيته ابقى معنا فادي
منصور
ونبقى في واشنطن ينضم الى
المستشار السابق لشؤون الامن القومي
الامريكي ومدير مكتبه
السابق مرحبا بك سيد ديفيد اولا لماذا
اتخذ
الديمقراطيون هذا الموقف ولم ينصروا كيفن
مكارسي
في الحقيقه اليوم نحن نشهد يوما تاريخيا
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حيث انها
وللمره الاولى نشهد فيها اطاحه برئيس مجلس
النواب من قبل اعضاء في حزبه بالنسبه الى
الحزب الديمقراطي وسلوك هذا المنحه في
العمليه السياسيه اذا ما كان الخصم يرتكب
اخطاء يجب ان لا تتدخل في مساره دعه يرتكب
هذه الاخطاء وهذا ما قام به كاظم بكارتي
على مر الاشهر العشر الماضيه هناك
تصرفات غريبه حصلت بعد وصوله الغريب في
يناير الى رئاسه مجلس النواب كان لديه
عشره اشهر لكي يبني التحالفات ويحصل على
الاصوات ولا لكي يكافح من الداخل من داخل
الحزب الجمهوري ضد الاشخاص الذين
ليسوا معه وايضا ضد الديمقراطيين وبالتالي
الديمقراطيون لم يكن لديهم اهتمام في
الاساس الاسبوع الماضي دعموه بالنسبه الى
مساله الميزانيه ولكنه على وجه الخصوص
القى اللوم على الديمقراطين وبالتالي يطرح
السؤال لماذا يلقى الدعم منهم طيب وهل
هناك من شخصيه ستلقى الدعم من
الديمقراطيين
ويلوح شبح الاغلاق
الحكومي بعد 45 يوما
نعم صحيح
نحن نتحدث عن مسائل حساسه سوف يتم التناقش
بشانها مساله الميزانيه
لوزارات الاساسيه وللجيش الامريكي الى
اخره الجمهوريون يتعين عليهم ان يتوصلوا
الى اسم شخصيه مرشحه يمكنها ان تحصل على
دعما من الطرف الاخر لحشد الاصوات
الضروريه هناك فرصه للتوصل الى نوع من
انواع الاتفاق ولكن هذه المساله اتت بعد
اخفاقات السيد مكارتي لقدر ارتكب سلسله
فظيعه من الاخطاء ولم يكن لديه تحالف جيد
يستند اليه قد يحاول ان يترشح لمره جديده
ولكنني اعتقد انها المره الاخيره التي
نراه فيها رئيسا لمجلس النواب
طيب نعود الى الشخصيه التي يفضلها
الديمقراطيون
رئيس لمجلس النواب في هذه المرحله
الحزب الديمقراطي وبالنظر الى حقيقه عملهم
على عمليه
مواجهه محاوله عزل الرئيس
الحالي اذا هناك عدد قليل من الجمهوريين
الذين يمكن ان يحضوا بدعم الديمقراطيين في
نظري الى مواقفهم اعتقدوا ان الحزب
الجمهوري لديه عدد من المرشحين لديه
اكثريه ليست عارمه ولكن الحزب الجمهوري هو
من يتعين عليه ان يضبط الامور ويرتب البيت
الداخلي قبل بدل اليد الى الديمقراطيين
للحصول على دعم الحزبطي وبالتالي الامور
متروكه الى ايدي مؤثري الحزب الجمهوري
والكره في ملعب الحزب الجمهوري بالنسبه
الى الشخص
المقبله لربما يمكن التوصل الى اتفاق على
مستوى
الحزب لا اعرف كيف سوف تحل هذه المساله
قريبا خصوصا وان الجزء المتشدد
والراديكالي من الحزب الجمهوري هو الذي
يسيطر وهو لا يقدم التنازلات ولكن
الديمقراطيين سوف يحاولون ان يدعموا
المؤسسات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولكن الى حدود معينه في نهايه المطاف
وبالتالي يتوقف الامر على اسم الشخصيه
والنظر فيما اذا كان باستطار ديمقراطيين
ان يتخلصوا من اي محاولات لعزل الرئيس
الامريكي او التحقيق بشكل
ابقى معنا ابقى معنا سنعود سنعود اليك
بالتاكيد سيد ديفيد لكن اود هنا ان انتقل
من جديد الى الى
ضيفنا من واشنطن
سادي بروس الان بعد كل ما جرى هذا الوضع
الذي بدت فيه الولايات المتحده على اعتاب
الانتخابات في ظل بدء الحملات الانتخابيه
بشكل او باخر من الذي يستفيد منه بطريقه
اكبر
اعتقد انه في الامد القريب للغايه الحزب
الديمقراطي هو الذي يستفيد ولكن اعتقد انه
من الغريب ان نقول ان الحزب الجمهوري هو
الذي تخلى عن السيد مكارثي اذا فقط ثمانيه
اشخاص
صوتوا ضد مكارتي ما كان ليطاح به لو لم
يصوت الديمقراطيون ضد مكارتي اعتقد انه في
الامد القريب سوف يبدو ان الحزب الجمهوري
في فوضى عارمه وهذا يمكن ان ينسحب على
السباق الرئاسي ايضا بالنظر الى
اللوائح الاتهاميه التي توجه الى الرئيس
ترامب والقضيه المدنيه بالنسبه الى
الاحتيال الى اخره هذا الامد القريب
بالنسبه الى الحزب الديمقراطي اذا ما لم
يمد اليد باتجاه المعتدلين من الجمهوريين
اعتقد ان الامور سوف ترتد عليهم الاحد
الماضي
الديمقراطيون راوا انه من مصلحتهم ان
ياتلفوا مع عدد مناسب من الجمهوريين
للتوصل الى الاقرار وهذا ما كان بالامكان
لو لم يمدوا اليد الى الجانب الاخر لذلك
لست متشائما بالنسبه الى عمل الحزب
الديمقراطي لربما باستطاعه الحزب
الديمقراطي ان ينخرط في عمل مشترك مع
الحزب الجمهوري للتوصلي الى شخصيه معتدله
في اوساط الحزب الجمهوري لا اعتقد ان
الديمقراطيين سوف يتشددون ويقولون بغض
النظر عن الشخصيه التي يرشحها الجمهوريون
سوف نصوت ضدها لا اعتقد ان هذا الموقف هو
الموقف الديمقراطي شكرا
النائب وزير العدله الامريكي سابقا
والخبير القانوني كنت معنا من واشنطن
ونعود الى ضيفنا في
نيويورك محمد اسطوحي الكاتب الصحفي المختص
في شان الامريكي اذا سيد الصطوحي الان
يعني الكثير من التحليلات الكثير من
الاسماء التي تطرح والمواقف
المتوقعه من كلا الطرفين لكن
ستكون هناك اجتماعات بين اعضاء الحزبين كل
على حده كما كما اعلن للاتفاق هل ترى ان
الجمهوريين
قادرون على الاقل ان يخففوا من اختلافاتهم
في الوقت الحاضر للاتفاق على شخصيه تكون
شخصيه وسطيه اذا اذا صح التعبير ولا تكرر
يعني تجربه كاظم في مجلس النواب
بدايه سيكون من الصعب الوصول الى تلك
الشخصيه لكن الاهم انه حتى لو وصلوا الى
تفاهم بشانها وتمكنوا من انتخاب هذا الشخص
كرئيس جديد للمجلس فانه هذا لن يحل مشكله
الحرب الاهليه الحقيقيه انا لا اقولها
مبالغه هناك بالفعل حرب اهليه داخل الحزب
الجمهوري الان
وهذا سيعوق اي رئيس جديد الى انه يؤدي
مهمه بطريقه صحيحه ما لم يتفاهم
تتفاهم الاغلبيه مع تلك المجموعه من
الاقليه على سياسات مشتركه يمكن فرضها
ويمكن التعامل بشانها وقبلها جزئيا من
الديمقراطين لانه من الممكن ان يمرر مجلس
النواب شيئا ثم تذهب الى مجلس الشيوخ
باغلبيته الديمقراطيه فيتم الغاؤها وبدء
خطه جديده فيكون هناك صراع بين مجلسينواب
ومجلس الشيوخ فحتى اذا وصلوا الى اتفاق لا
يرضي الديمقراطيين اذهب الى مكتب الرئيس
الامريكي فيستخدم حقه في الفيتو الرئاسي
اذا نحن نتحدث عن عمليه سياسيه معقده
تستدعي في الاساس ان يكون هناك تفاهم كما
يوصف عقروزدا لاين انه انا اتفاهم مع
الحزب الاخر للوصول الى سياسات من الممكن
ان نتفق من خلالها على الحد الادنى
المشترك الذي نقبل به معا مع وجود تطرفات
في الطرفين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين وانه
هؤلاء المتطرفون هم الذين يسيطرون على
الاجنده بشكل كبير ويمكنهم حتى ان يعاقبوا
من يخرج على اهدافهم المتطرفه كما راينا
اليوم فانه اي رئيس جديد سيجد نفسه رهينه
لهذه المجموعه المتطرفه وعندما يكون هو
نفسه ذاهبا الى انتخابات لمجلس النواب
خلال اشهر قليله فانه هو نفسه مقعده من
الممكن ان يتهدد ما لم يستجب للاجنده
المتطرفه لتلك المجموعه المتطرفه فانا
يعني انا اعتقادي انه نحن امامنا عام من
الصراع من الممكن ان يصلوا الى اتفاق على
شخص ما لكن صدقني انا لا اهتم باسم هذا
الشخص اهتم اكثر بالمعادله السياسيه التي
سيعمل من خلالها والتي تجعله في كل
الاحوال في موقف صعب للغايه طيب ما الذي
اوصل الامور الى هذا الحد يعني هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي يكون هناك هذا الكباش
داخل مجلس النواب بين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين او بين الجمهوريين انفسهم لكن
هل الحاله الانتخابيه هي التي اوصلت الى
هذه المعادله الصعبه
امم الموضوع موضوع الانفاق فعلا
ودعم اوكرانيا مثلا هو هو الذي اوصل الى
ما وصل اليه
يعني طبعا هذه مجرد اعراض انا اتابع
السياسه الامريكيه عن قرب وخصوصا الكونجرس
بالتحديد لاني اعتبره هو موقع العمل
السياسي الحقيقي في الولايات المتحده منذ
91 من اكثر من 30 سنه
الكونجرس فيه مشكله تعبر عن ثقافه سياسيه
فيها انقسامات كبيره تزداد فيها الفجوه
بين التيارات المختلفه
عندما كنت في واشنطن منذ في التسعينات
الى ما يخرج من عده سنوات سابقه كنا نجد
احيانا بعض الشخصيات التي يمكنها ان
تتفاهم معا عبر الحزبين وصلوا الى اتفاقات
وتفاهمات كان جو بايدن رئيسا للجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه او رئيسا للمجموعه
الديمقراطيه عندما يفقدون الاغلبيه كندا
اجده صديقا للغايه مع ريتشار لوجر الذي
كان زعيما للجمهوريين في لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه كان بينهما ود كبير وتفاهم اليوم
عندما يتحدث جو بايدن عن متش ماكانال زعيم
الاقليه الجمهوريه في مجلس الشيوخ يقول
انني احبه وكنا دائما ما نستطيع ان نتفاهم
في العمل ولكني اخشى ان هذا سيضر في الحزب
الجمهوري وهو يعني ما يقوله لانه اذا شعر
الجمهوريون او القاعده الجمهوريه بانه
متفاهم مع جو بايدن او ان بينهما صداقه
شخصيه هذا قد يضر به السياسيا لدى القاعده
المتشدده في الحزب الجمهوري هناك تحولات
كبيره في الثقافه السياسيه والقاعده من
الجمهوريه وبالمناسبه حتى بين نسبه كبيره
من الديمقراطيين دعني اقول لك انه هلري
كلينتون خسرت الانتخابات اساسا لانه
المجموعه المتشدده من الديمقراطيين والتي
كانت تدعم
رات انه لا استطيع ان ادعم هيلر كلينتون
في الانتخابات لن تسرق سيارتي ثم امونها
بالبنزين بعد ذلك هذا ما كان يقوله لبعض
المتشددين من انصار بين نيسان
هذا التشدد لدى القاعده السياسيه بين
الجمهورين وبين الديمقراطيين هو الذي يخلق
الان ذلك المناخ الذي يجعل من الصعوبه
داخل مجلس النواب او حتى في مجلس الشيوخ
ان يستطيعوا ان يتفهموا على خطط مشتركه اي
شيء يتم تمريره بصعوبه بالغه حتى اذا
وصلوا الى اتفاقات هذا معناه الكثير من
المناورات السياسيه والجهود ومحاوله
مخاطره القاعده بلغه متشدده تجعلهم لا
يفقدون دعمها في الانتخابات القادمه حتى
ان كانوا يمارسون في السر بعض التفاهمات
مع الحزب الاخر من اجل الوصول الى اتفاق
طالما استمرت هذه الثقافه السياسيه وهذا
الانقسام المتشدد بين التيارات المختلفه
اعتقد انه هذا سيكون هو المشكله وهو ما
نرى اعراضه الان التي تتحدث عنها وهي في
النهايه
اعراض حتى لو توصلوا الى اتفاق على تمويل
الحرب في اوكرانيا او الجدار العازل هذا
لن يحل لتلك المشكله
شكرا لك سيد محمد
سطوحي
ونتابع مشاهدينا ايضا من البيت الابيض مع
مراسله الجزيره وجد وقتي وجد اود ان اطرح
عليك هذا السؤال وستتابع معك الزميله
مياده هذه التغطيه اولا هل صدرت اي مواقف
في البيت الابيض
بشان ما حصل في مجلس النواب من عزل كيف
تبدو الاجواء بعد هذه السابقه التي حصلت
هناك
نعم حتى اللحظه حسن لم يصدر اي بيان او اي
خطاب من البيت الابيض ازاء عزل مقرتي هناك
صمت تام هنا في البيت الابيض اذا ما يجري
في الكونغرس وربما هذا يبرره بان هذا
الامر شان داخلي بين الاعضاء الجمهوريين
داخل مجلس النواب
الجمهوريون المتشددون
والغالبيه الجمهوريه لهذا ربما لم يصدر
حتى اللحظه بيان من البيت الابيض كونه كما
ذكرنا بيان داخلي الان ما يجري في
الكونغرس حقيقه انتهت اعمال اليوم
تمت تم عزل كفن مقرفي الاطاحه به للمره
الاولى في تاريخ الولايات المتحده
وانفض مجلس النواب ما هو متوقع غدا بحسب
بعض تصريحات الديمقراطيين في مجلس النواب
هو ان يجتمع كل حزب على غدا لانه حتى لو
ان الان هناك رئيس مؤقت لمجلس النواب او
قائم باعمال رئيس مجلس النواب فينبغي ان
يكون هناك رئيس دائم للمجلس نظرا للملفات
الكثيره ومشاريع القوانين ولعل اهمها
الميزانيه الموجوده امام المجلس والتي
ينبغي ان يصوت عليها قبل انقضاء الخمسه
واربعين يوما وهي مهله التمديد للميزانيه
وبالتالي ملفات كثيره امام المجلس لهذا
يتوقع ان يجتمع غدا الديمقراطيون لاختيار
حكيم جافريز وهو زعيم الاقليه الديمقراطيه
في مجلس النواب ليكون هو مرشحهم لرئاسه
الحزب وايضا الجمهوريون قد يجتمعوا غدا من
اجل التوافق على
مرشح للجمهوريين وهنا حقيقه التحدي
الحقيقي امام الجمهوريين هل يقبل ستيف
الذي
يعاني من المرض ويخضع لعلاج حاليا هل يقبل
امر ايضا حقيقه لا نعلم حتى اللحظه
وبانتظار ما سيحدث غدا نشكرك حتى اللحظه
مراسله الجزيره وجد وقفي من البيت الابيض